ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS EIGHT
BACKER YEAH PORGES BRADFORD
CABRERO CORTEZ V. DALLY YEAH
GOD DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER AND
SOLACE GROVE HERTZBERG WEST SO
HER TADO. JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LLEVA DEMONA MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MEN NEWMAN MAIL SEND
A CHILL ABODE PAN FORTUNE TINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG
Y. CASKEY WINNER WELL. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY SENATOR LAYERED AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR PAN SENATOR LAYERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE FOLLOWING POEM
CALLED SHINE IS IN A KNOWLEDGE
MENT OF OUR WORK FOR THE COMMON
GOOD. FOR JUST THIS MOMENT AND
THE NEXT DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THIS WORLD CANNOT FEEL THE
INCREDIBLE GIFT. THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN GIVEN AND HOLD. THERE'S NO
COMPARISON TO YOU. THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE ANOTHER AHEAD OF YOU
AND JUST BEHIND YOU ON THE
PATH. ONE IS BECKONING FOR YOU
TO FOLLOW IN THE WAKE OF THEIR
WISDOM AND THE OTHER IS
CLINGING TO YOU. FOR HELP AND
GUIDANCE. ARE YOU TO BE THE
STUDENT OR THE TEACHER. YOU'VE
BEEN GRANTED THE PLEASURE OF
EXPERIENCING BOTH. AS THEY ARE
MEANT TO BE ONE. WHAT THIS
WORLD HAS LED US TO BELIEVE AS
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES ARE
THE TOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
TO CARVE OUT OUR UNIQUE PURPOSE.
IT'S TIME. DEAR SENATORS TO
ALLOW THE ART OF YOUR LIFE TO
BE SEEN AND HEARD FROM EVERY
ANGLE OF THE BEAUTIFUL
SCULPTURE YOU'RE CREATING
CONSIDER WITH LOVE THAT ALL WHO
ARE RECEIVING YOUR GIFT ARE
DOING SO FROM THE BREADTH OF
THE MOMENT WE ARE STEPPING.
UPON LOVING GOD WE ASK YOU TO
BE WITH US IN THIS MOMENT AS WE
SEEK TO CARVE OUT OR UNIQUE
PURPOSE WITH ALL ITS CHALLENGES
AND CREATIVITY. A MAN. A. AND
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SO ALL. GOOD MORNING REMEMBER
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I WOULD
LIKE TO WISH SENATOR CORTESE A
VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY ALTHOUGH HE
IS OFF THE FLOOR NOW BUT LET US
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM WHEN HE
DISCOVERS THAT THERE IS OKAY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY CENTER CORTESE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBER FOR MOVINGA
MOTION RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
THIS WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO MOVE ANY BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY BILLS THAT THEY NEED TO
MOVE SENATOR GONZALEZ. YES
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU- I
WILL ADD FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
WHICH IS SP THREE FOR TWO TO
THE ACTIVE WE WILL BE BACK IN
JANUARY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I REQUEST THAT FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE- SP TWO
THIRTY FOUR BE MOVED TO BEING
ACTIVE FILES. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE IN AND
THIRTY THREE S. B. FOUR FOUR
FOUR TO THE ACTIVE. THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR RUSSELL. YES
MA'AM PRESIDENT I ASKED THAT
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE IS B.
FOUR EIGHT ONE HE SENT TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO MEMBERS OTHER ANY
OTHER BILLS THAT NEED TO BE
REMOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ABOUT A PRESIDENT I THINK
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH HER ON
BEHALF OF CENTER LATE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS TO AN
ACTIVE FILE ITEM NINETEEN IS B.
TWO OH FIVE LEAVE A- FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT IS P. FIFTY THREE
LEVELS. IN FILE ITEM THIRTY SP
SP SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU IN
PERSON THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE CENTER BATES. PRESIDENT
OF THE PARTY REQUEST. TO REMOVE
FILE- NUMBER THIRTEEN SB SIX
FIFTY TWO TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES CENTER
GLAZER I DID NOTE THAT YOU WERE
AT THE MICROPHONE TO DO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO
MOVE. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU I GUESS THAT- FILE IN
TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN NINETY
NINE. AND FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
SB SEVEN EIGHT FIVE BE MOVED TO
AN AFTER. THINKCENTRE GLAZER
THE DESK WILL NOTE MEMBERS
ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY BILLS THAT
THEY NEED TO MOVE TO AN ACTIVE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN. WE
WILL MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WHICH IS FILE
ITEM NINE SENATOR BATES PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. YEAH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF MELANIE SHELBY AND MARK TONY
TO THE STATE BAR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES MICHELLE B. HAS BEEN
MANAGING DIRECTOR IS GREAT
GREER SHELBY AND YVONNE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT MR TONY HAS
BEEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
TWENTY SIXTH ON- UNANIMOUS VOTE
FIVE ZERO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. I BASE. I BECKER I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI ABOUT
EURO. CORTESE HI DALLY FIVE DOT.
HI TORONTO. HI ADNAN HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH FIVE
HURTS BERG FIVE WEST SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER HI
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN PHOTO OF BOTH
HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE
E. FIVE WINNER HI WELK I DIDN'T
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM TWELVE
SENATOR STERN ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT FOLLOWED I'M TWELVE.
SENATOR STERN. FILE I'M. TWELVE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO WATER CLEANER FROM. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ARRIVED PRISONERS BEFORE EIGHTY
RECENTLY. THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
TROUBLING REPORTS OF.
HARASSMENT OTHER UNACCEPTABLE
AND INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT- FOR
ONE OF THE PREEMINENT. WATER
AGENCIES IN NOT JUST THE STATE
BUT THE WHOLE WORLD
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT THEIR
WORK FORCE- HAS BEEN SUFFERING.
AND YEAH IT'S TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. SET SOME
PARAMETERS FOR. THE KIND OF
RULES WE PUT IN PLACE YEARS
AGO- FOR OURSELVES AND FOR
OTHERS IT HOPEFULLY IS IMPROVE
CONDUCT AT THE WORKPLACE ITSELF
IN FEBRUARY ONLY TIMES LAUNCHED
AN INVESTIGATION INTO YEARS OF
COMPLAINTS THE MAN FILED THE
COMPLETE THE MEMBERS THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. AND
MANY OF THOSE HAVE BEEN IGNORED.
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY AN
ALREADY UNDER WAY AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S SOME PROGRESS
BEING MADE THERE WE DO
APPRECIATE- THE EFFORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN GOING ON TO
INVESTIGATE THE VALIDITY AND
EXTENT OF THESE ALLEGATIONS.
BUT THERE CAN AND SHOULD BE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT ARE DRESSED
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME OF
THIS ON. NO PERSON SHOULD FEEL
UNSAFE IN THEIR WORK. IT SHOULD
BE NO ROOM FOR DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT IT'S AN MEMBER OF
SOCIETY AND PUBLIC ENTITIES
SUCH AS THIS LEGISLATURE. AND
MEN. SHOULD BE HELD TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARD WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR CONTACT. THIS BEFORE HE
REQUIRES THAT. MANY DOCTOR
ROLES THE REFLECT THESE VALUES
AND- PARTICULAR EMPLOYEES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D ONLY
ADD THAT WE ALSO INCLUDE THE
CURRENT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WHO'S UNDER TREMENDOUS
HARASSMENT THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO. EVER HIT
THAT AGENCY AND THE TREATMENT
THAT SHE HAS RECEIVED VERSUS
THE MAIL ARE SICK OF PEOPLE WHO
PRECEDED HER IS STARTLING IN IT
OFITSELF AND SHE NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN MOVING FORWARD ON THE SIDE
AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MEMBERS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NINE CENTER ST WE
TRIED TO CLOSE RESPECT FASTER
THANK YOU SIR MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS. HI BETH.
I BACKER HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I CAN BUY A- CORTESE
HI DALLY I DON. HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH
HI- TIDO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED BY LABOR HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA I MEN I KNEW.
HI NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO I ROTH I
GREW. I SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M BERG. RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER HI WELL I DIDN'T
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
ALSO SENATOR STERN
MISUNDERSTAND ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PREVENT ITEM FIFTEEN.
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR STERN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
FOLLOWED IN FIFTEEN. IS THAT A
YES OR NO THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETEEN BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. ARRESTERS INDUSTRY
FOR NINETEEN I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
I'M HAVING WITH THE NUMBER OF
MY COLLEAGUES OVER THE PAST-
WEEKS IN LEADING UP TO THIS
PRESENTATION AND I HAVE NO
DOUBT THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE- WE HAVE
A- AN IMPORTANT INDUSTRY- WITH.
WITH THE COMPLEX FUTURE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS
THAT ARE RIDING ON THE FUTURE-
WE'RE TALKING TO THE OIL AND
GAS SECTOR HERE TODAY. AND TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
ONLY GAS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY THE WORKERS WHO DO
pGOOD BENEFITS- AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO SERVICING OUR
WILL SENSE THE PLACES THAT ARE
CLOSEST TO OUR COMMUNITIES TWO
MILLION PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN A
HALF MILE. I GAS WELL IN
CALIFORNIA- YOU DESERVE THE
VERY BEST. THIS THIS BILL-
WOULD WOULD START TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES WE'VE SEEN
IN MIDSTREAM SERVICES- IN THE
EXTRACTION PROCESS ITSELF IN
THE PLUGGING AND ABANDONING
PROCESS WHERE A LOT OF THE WORK
WE'RE DOING ISN'T COMING
LOCALLY OR EVEN- FROM OUR LOCAL
LABOR UNIONS OR SUBCONTRACTORS
BUT FROM OUT OF STATE. THEY
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE ALSO MANY
PEOPLE IN THE STATE WHO DO THIS
WORK IT MAY NOT BE PART OF A
TRADE UNION AT THIS POINT- AND-
THERE IS NO INTENTION IN THIS
MEASURE. TO PUT THOSE PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK. SIMPLY TO WRITE A
PATHWAY. TO BEING PART OF A
MORE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. FOR A PARTICULAR.
CLASS OF WORKER. AND THE WORK
IS BEING PERFORMED WITH THESE
WELL SITES. CAN BE DONE
CORRECTLY OR INCORRECTLY AND
THAT CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE HEALTH PROPERTY OR
VIRAL PROTECTION. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- CONSTRUCTION DEMOLITION
INSTALLATION REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE WORK IN AND THIS
BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO BE AN
INDICTMENT. OF THE CURRENT WORK
GOING ON IN OUR FIELDS- THERE
IS SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER AT
STAKE THOUGH. WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE LIVES LIVE IN THE
SHADOWS OF THESE OIL AND GAS-
IT'S- THOUGHT THAT PEOPLE COULD
BE COMING IN FROM TEXAS TO DO
THIS WORK- AND DISPLACING OUR
OWN CALIFORNIA WORKERS IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. SO WITH
THIS PHONE HERE TODAY WE'RE
HOPING TO FIND SOME GROUND TO
WORK ON AS A LEGISLATURE- BY
NOT NECESSARILY SAYING-
FIGHTING THE FIGHT OVER THE
FUTURE OF OIL BUT SAYING TO THE
EXTENT WE ARE PRODUCING OIL AND
EVEN WHEN WE GO TO TAKE CARE OF
BRANDON WELLS AND- AND PLUGGING
IN FOR MEDIATION BUT THAT WORK
IS DONE. BY SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKS THE VERY BEST IN THE
WORLD. SO WITH THAT LOOK FOR
THE CONVERSATION AS WE GO
FORWARD- AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM. RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I'M
GONNA TRY TO HOLD IT TOGETHER
BECAUSE YOU GUYS KNOW I DEEPLY
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT MY DISTRICT.
IN THIS BILL ADVERSELY AFFECTS
ALMOST TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
WORKERS IN MY DISTRICT. TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT ARE
55% OF PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE R.
SIX POINT 5% WOMEN. THEY'RE 18%
UNITED STATES MILITARY VETERANS
WITH TRANSFERABLE SKILLS. AND
THEY ARE 30% SECOND CANCERS WE
GET SECOND CHANCES FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE WERE PAROLE
OFFICERS GIVE HIM. A PASS OR
WHATEVER TEY HAVE TO APPLY FOR
TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE LA COUNTY
OR- SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY OR
WHEREVER THEIR FRIEND. TO MOVE
TO A SEPARATE COUNTY-
CONTINUOUS COUNTY SO THAT THEY
CAN APPLY TO WORK IN THE OIL
FIELDS. INDIVIDUALS LIKE JERRY
FLORES WHO WOULD FOLLOW HIS
FATHER AND GRANDFATHER. TO PULL
SOME ON THEM. HIGH SCHOOL THE
FULL SOME PIPELINE IS WHAT HE
CALLS IT- JERRY FLORES WAS IN
AND OUT OF PRISON AND HE MAKES
US HUMAN HE TELLS HIS STORY HE
SAYS THAT. HIS MOM USED TO GET
TOGETHER WITH FOR BAIL MONEY
AND NOW HE'S WITH FUEL INDUSTRY
IN THE JOB THAT HE GETS WITH
THE EXCELLENT BENEFITS.
EXCELLENT PAY PACKAGE HE
STARTED OUT AS A GENERAL LABOR
AND NOW HE IS A SUPERVISOR
WHERE HE ACTUALLY MOVES ADD THE
BUYING AND SELLING OF OIL
PRODUCT. IS A COMPANY TRUCK
HE'S A HONEST KIDS PTA HIS SON
JUST GOT A- SCHOLARSHIP TO
HAWTHORNE UNIVERSITY- HUMBOLDT
UNIVERSITY. AND IT CHANGED HIS
LIFE. IT CHANGED HIS LIFE AND
IT CHANGES KIDS LIVES WITH
GENERATIONAL. LIKE MR VALDEZ
WHO AM FOUND HIMSELF IN AND OUT
OF PRISON HE LOST HIS WIFE AND
HIS MOTHER RAISED HIS
DAUGHTERS- IN THE PARK WHEN HE
WAS NOT AVAILABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM. AND THEN HE RECENTLY
REMARRIED AND HE'S USING THE
INCOME THAT HE'S ABLE TO USE
AND MAKE FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY.
TO PETITION FOR HIS WIFE TO
HAVE RESIDENCY- THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT ON A PETITION
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
CAN FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THEM.
PEOPLE LIKE MISTER TAYLOR AND
JAMAL AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
WORKED IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
DECADES- SOME ONLY A FEW YEARS
BUT MR TAYLOR HAS WORKED THERE
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND HE'S
TAKING CARE OF HIS FAMILY. HE'S
PAYING FOR HIS KIDS TO GO TO
COLLEGE. THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE
I AM FRANKIE NOTICE FRANCIS HE
WAS A PHOTO. OF A PERSON THAT
CAME OUT OF PRISON IN WOMEN-
SHE WENT THROUGH THE OIL
INDUSTRY TRAINING PROGRAM AND
SHE'S BEEN WORKING IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY FOR ELEVEN YEARS AND
SHE JUST RECENTLY GOT PROMOTED
TO A SAFETY POSITION WHERE SHE
HAS A COMPANY TRUCK. AND
THERE'S- BENEFITS AND GREAT PAY.
I I SHOULD START BY SAYING I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
COMMUNICATION WITH ME ON THIS
BILL. IN AND WORKING WITH ME
I'M TRYING TO GET HIM TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS WOULD GUARANTEE.
THAT THESE PEOPLE WOULD NOT
LOSE THEIR JOB. I TALK TO THE
AUTHOR AND HE SAID THE BILL IS
SILENT ON THAT WHICH IT IS THE
BILL IS SILENT ON THAT IT SAYS
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THEY WILL
LOSE THEIR JOB. BUT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE IN THIS BILL WITHOUT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT- THEY WON'T
LOSE THEIR JOB FOR THE POSITION
THAT THEY HAVE. THE BILL IS A
PREMISE ABOUT SAFETY SOMEONE TO
GO INTO THAT. LEGISLATION THAT
HAS BEEN PASSED IN THIS THIS
BUILDING IN THE PAST- OVER THE
LAST FEW DECADES IS REQUIRED
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO REPORT THEIR-
INCIDENTS- LAST TIME INCIDENCES
IT'S RECORDED ON OSHA THREE
HUNDRED LOG THAT'S POSTED
PUBLICLY EVERY YEAR FOR THIRTY
DAYS. AND THEN THAT INFORMATION
IS ALSO REPORTED TO THE BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS THE CAL
OSHA DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS WEBSITE. WHERE THAT
IF INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL OF US AND THE PUBLIC TO SEE
WHAT INDUSTRIES. ARE CONSIDERED
SAFE. SO BASED ON CALIFORNIA
STATE CALIFORNIA'S WEBSITE YOUR
OWN WEBSITE. FOR THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS IN CAL OSHA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AG INDUSTRY
THE T. R. I. R. WHICH IS THE
TOTAL REPORTED INCIDENT RATE
SO. EVERY TIME YOU HAVE AN
INCIDENT AN ACCIDENT YOU HAVE
TO REPORT THIS. SO IF YOU TAKE
THE AG INDUSTRY THE AGNES TREES
FIVE POINT SEVEN. FIVE POINT
SEVEN. THE OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION INDUSTRY IS POINT
EIGHT. NOT EIGHT POINT EIGHT
POINT EIGHT- WASTE WATER SEWER-
RELATED CONTRACTS CONTRACTORS
THESE ARE ALL CONTRACTORS THAT
WORK FOR- THAT- YOU KNOW
LICENSE CONTRACTORS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT- WASTE WATER SEWER LINE
RELATED STRUCTURES THAT DO
MUNICIPALITY WATER LINE
STRUCTURES AND INSTALL WATER
LINES ON IT FOR THE
MUNICIPALITIES THEY ARE AND
ACCORDING TO THE WEBSITE TWO
POINT ONE. THE PEOPLE THAT DO
THESE INSTALLATIONS OF WATERS
WATER SEWERS ARE TWO POINT ONE
WHICH IS CONSIDERED IN THE
POSTION STATE. NOW IF YOU LOOK
AT OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION OIL
AND GAS PIPELINE THE POINT
EIGHT. THAT IS IN THE GREEN
STAGE OCEAN ISN'T EVEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY THAT
THEY HAVE IN THE OIL FIELDS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN EXCELLENT
SAFETY PROGRAM THAT WAS
DESIGNED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND I'LL SHARE THAT INFORMATION
IN A SECOND. IF YOU LOOK AT
THEM. OIL AND GAS RELATED
STRUCTURES WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL. COVERS ITS
POINT FIVE SIX FOR ABOVE
GROUND. ANY TYPE OF THE
BACKGROUND OF BELOW GROUND
WORK. IF YOU JUST TAKE KERN
COUNTY BECAUSE- AGAIN MY
DISTRICT IN KERN COUNTY HAS 70%
7% OF THE STATE'S OIL AND GAS.
THAT'S WHERE 70% OF THE WORKERS
IN THE OIL AND GAS LIVE BREED
RAISE THEIR FAMILIES. PLAY
BASEBALL AND GO TO CHURCH OR
HAVE FAMILY ACTIVITIES THEY
DON'T COME FROM TEXAS. THEY
DON'T COME FROM OTHER STATES.
THEY ARE NINETY NINE POINT 9%
RESIDENTS OF OUR COMMUNITY. AND
THEY HAVE GREAT JOBS IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY IF YOU JUST TAKE THAT
DISTRICT WHICH IS 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL NOT INCLUDING ANY
OTHER COUNTY THAT HAS OIL IN
THEIR DISTRICT. WE ARE EIGHT
POINT THREE THREE WITH ALL OF
THE CONTRACTORS AND I KNOW
THAT'S KIND OF HARD TO FOLLOW
BUT I WANT YOU TO MIX I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS. THAT THE PREMISE
OF THIS BILL THAT IS SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE DOES NOT
EXIST IN THE OIL FIELDS. IS
COMPLETELY ABSURD. IT REALLY
IS. THESE INDIVIDUALS WORK HARD
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE OIL
INDUSTRY'S THE MAJORS REALIZE
THAT. THEY NEED TO COME UP WITH
THE SAFETY PROGRAM THEY WERE
MANDATED TO DO THAT THEY WERE
LEGISLATED TO DO THAT. THEY
CARED ABOUT THE PEOPLE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
WENT HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES
SAFELY. SO THEY CAME TOGETHER
AND THEY WORK TO THE
ASSOCIATION CALLED ABC TO PUT
TOGETHER A MULTI CRAFT OIL AND
GAS TRAINING PROGRAM. WHICH IS
REQUIRED TO DO AND GO THROUGH
THIS TRAINING PROGRAM BEFORE
YOU CAN GO OUT TO ANY POSITION
IN THE OIL FIELDS I DON'T CARE
IF YOU'RE JUST. SHOPPING WEEDS
WERE A LOT OF OUR WEST TECH
WHICH IS OUR- CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY PEOPLE THAT START
THERE. IS IF THEY CAN SHOW UP
ON TIME AND THEY CAN SHOW UP
EVERY DAY. AND THEY CAN JUST
CHOP WEEDS CAN BE- YOU KNOW. IT
JUST SHOW UP TO SHOW THAT
THEY'LL BE CONSISTENT THEN
THEY'LL ELEVATOR A LOT OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL STARTED. ON THAT
WEEK FOR MAINTENANCE CREW. AND
NOW THEY RUN COMPLETELY FULL
OPERATIONS IN INCLUDING WATER
TREE THIS. WHERE WE TAKE WATER
THE IS PART. OUT OF THE OIL
WELLS AND WE TURN IT INTO GOOD
WATER. HAVE A PERMIT AND USE IT
TO GIVE IT TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY. THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE RUNNING THOSE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. IF YOU LOOK AT. THEM
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SAFETY P.
SEVEN THIS BILL HAS NO STANDING
WHATSOEVER. JUST BECAUSE OF THE
NAME AND NUMBERS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF US ON THE
WEB SITE. AT THE BELIEVER
STIFFNESS TO STATISTICS. THE
AUTHOR SAYS THAT THIS BILL IS
SILENT ON THE FACT THAT THESE
PEOPLE DON'T. HAVE TO LEAVE
THEIR JOBS BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BILL LANGUAGE ITSELF. AND
YOU GO TO PAGE THREE. IT SAYS
THAT. IT HAPPENED TO THEM THE
TREE IT SAYS THAT I'M IN THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE
PAID AT LEAST THE REPUBLIC TO
PREVAILING WAGES A DIRTY
PERSON. A PERSON. FOR WAGING
OCCUPATION. TO BE REGISTERED
AND APPROVED PRETTY SHIP
PROGRAM. SO LIKE I SAID I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE PREVAILING WAGES
FOR CERTAIN OPERATIONS BUT I
CAN TELL YOU A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE MAKING X. EXCESS OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. THE MINIMUM WAGE THAT
THEY GET PAID IS ALMOST TWENTY
ONE DOLLARS AN HOUR WHEN THEY
GO OUT TO THE OIL FIELD TO
START ON A WEAKER. NOW I KNOW
THAT SAN FRANCISCO AND- YOU
KNOW THE- PLACES AND BIG
METROPOLIS AREAS THAT'S NOT A
VERY GOOD WAGE BECAUSE IT COSTS
A LOT OF MONEY TO LIVE IN THOSE
CITIES BUT- OUR COST OF LIVING
HAS BEEN MAINTAINED IN THE
STATE IN KERN COUNTY AND THAT'S
EVEN A GREAT WAIT FOR SOMEBODY
TO START OUT IN. THE OIL FIELDS.
THIS BILL ON LINE ITEM NINE
REQUIRES THAT APPRENTICES ARE
REGISTERED PROGRAMS ARE
APPROVED BY THE CHIEF DIVISION
OF APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS.
AND THAT THEY HAVE PROPER
CHAINING TRAINING ON THE JOB IN
SUPERVISION. THEIR REQUIREMENT
THAT AT LEAST SIXTY PERCENT-
JOURNEY LEVEL. THE PRINTER.
OFFER KEEP UP. THE
APPRENTICESHIP OCCUPATION MEANS
THE OCCUPATION FOR WHICH THE
CHIEF IS APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. IT SAYS
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS BEEN
ISSUED A CERTIFICATE UNDER THE
AUTHORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP. COUNCIL AND THE
CHIEF COMPLETING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM APPROVED. BY SECTION
THREE OH SEVEN BY LABOR CODE.
SAYS THE INDIVIDUAL HAS TO
COMPLETE AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM LOCATED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA APPROVED FEDERAL%
PURPOSES. IF HE SAYS THEY HAVE
TO BE A REGISTERED APPRENTICE.
IT HAS TO SEE IT WHEN YOU GO
DOWN TO THE BOTTOM OF PAGE AND-
FIVE OR SKEWS ME FOR AND IT'S A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
NEEDS A WORK FORCE THAT. BOTH
HAS THIS NUMBER ONE. ALL
WORKERS. ARE EITHER REGISTERED
APPRENTICES OR SKILLED JOURNEY
LEVELS. AND NUMBER TWO AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWO OF THOSE-
PERCENTAGE PROCESS. THESE
WORKERS THAT HAVE WORKED SIX
MONTHS TWO YEARS FIVE YEARS TEN
YEARS MR TAYLOR'S BEEN OUT
THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS. THEY'RE
GOING TO DISTILL WILL TELL MR
TAYLOR MR FLOOR AS MR. VALDEZ
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU GUYS WERE
US TALKED. TO ON THE ZOOM
CALLS. WILL TELL. THEM THAT
THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO DO
THEIR JOB. THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO
A GOING TO THE BILL SAY THAT
GUYS ARE. TO BE LEGISLATE AND
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO TRAINING
TO BE A LEGISLATOR. I JUST I
IMPLORE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
DETAILS. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND THINK. THE FIFTEEN
COLLEAGUES. THE FIFTEEN CALLING
TO TAKE THE TIME OUT OF THEIR
DAY TO GET ON THE PHONE WITH
THESE EMPLOYEES AND LET THEM
SHARE THEIR- STORIES AND HOW
THIS IS THIS BILL WOULD
ADVERSELY AFFECT HIM. I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR TIME
I WANT TO THANK YOU THAT YOU
WITH THEM. THE USE LIKE I SAID
TOOK THE TIME OUT OF YOUR DAY
TO- TO MEET WITH THESE
EMPLOYEES I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR AT LEAST LISTENING
AND THE AUTHOR DID TAKE A PHONE
CALL WITH THESE EMPLOYEES HAD A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS. COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL AFFECTS EVERY SINGLE
CONTRACTOR THAT WORKS FOR THE
OIL INDUSTRY. THE MAJORS IN THE
OIL COMPANIES THE WAY IT WORKS
ON THE GROUND THEY DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF EMPLOYEES. THEY CONTRACT
OUT A HUGE PORTION OF THEIR
WORK IT'S THE CONTRACTORS WITH
THESE EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED. THESE EMPLOYEES WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH THIS
TRAINING PROGRAM I'VE ASKED THE
AUTHOR TO DO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
GUARANTEE. THAT THESE PEOPLE
WILL NOT LOSE THEIR JOB. AND
YOU KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT CHEVRON IS MOVING TOWARDS
A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT AND
THAT CHEVRON IS GOING TO-
REQUIRE CONTRACTORS TO WORK
UNDER PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS.
BUT I WANT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
WHICH I'VE GIVEN TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT GUARANTEES
THEIR JOB AND IT ALSO GIVES
THEM TIME TO GO THROUGH THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. IF THIS
BILL. PASSES IN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS IT IN NOVEMBER OR
OCTOBER. AND IT TAKES EFFECT IN
JANUARY THE MINIMUM TRAINING
COURSE FOR SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE ON AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM I BELIEVE IS TWO YEARS.
THERE'S NO WAY THESE EMPLOYEES
CAN LEAVE THEIR JOB FOR TWO
YEARS GO THROUGH A TRAINING
PROGRAM TO GO TO THE END OF THE
LINE AT THE UNION HALL THIS IS
NOT AN ANTI UNION BILL. I HAVE
TO APPLAUD THE UNIONS THEY
TREAT A LOT OF WATER FOR THE
OIL INDUSTRY YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS GOVERNOR AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE STARTED TO
SHUT DOWN THE OIL INDUSTRY IF
THE UNIONS HAD STEPPED UP IN
AND- AND HELP THEM. THIS IS NOT
AN ANTI UNION BILL THIS IS A
PRO WORKER BILL AND I NEED MY
PEOPLE AND I SEE MY PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND I FELT A LOT OF THEM GET
JOBS. I AM. A WANT THIS ONE
THAT PEOPLE REPRESENT THE OIL
INTO. IN MY DISTRICT IN THIS
STILL DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS CURRENT COUNTY. SO I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO- TO MEET WITH THESE
PEOPLE. AND TO LISTEN TO THEIR
STORIES. AND AGAIN THE PREMISE
OF THE BILL IS SAFETY THE DATA
ON THE WEBSITE DEBUNKS NOW. AND
I RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY BEG
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR WENER AND THEN SENATOR
ALAN SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR. FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE AS
BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY KNOW I'VE
BEEN. AND I'VE LEGISLATION ON
THIS. EARLIER THIS YEAR AN
ADVOCATE FOR MOVING CALIFORNIA
AWAY FROM OIL EXTRACTION. IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY WE NEED TO
PHASE OUT. OF FOSSIL FUEL
EXTRACTION IN CALIFORNIA- AND
FRANKLY ALTERNATELY. EVERYWHERE
BECAUSE WE'RE DESTROYING THE
PLANET- BY OUR OVER RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS- AND WE ARE AT
RISK OF CREATING A PLANET THAT
WILL BE UNINHABITABLE. FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN
AND WE HAVE THE FIRES AND THE
SEA LEVEL RISE IN THE FLOODING
AND EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND WE NEED TO
BE. HAVE A MUCH GREATER SENSE
OF URGENCY THEN FRANKLY THE
STATE HAS. ABOUT ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ENDING OUR
RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS ARE
MOVING AWAY FROM OIL
EXTRACTION- AND THIS BILL I
THINK WAS- INTRODUCED AS A PART
OF THAT CONVERSATION. BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
OIL INDUSTRY. THAT THERE IS A
REAL TRANSITION NOT TO LIKE
pTHE JOBS THAT ARE. A THOUSAND
MILES AWAY- BUT GOOD. JOBS IN
MY VIEW OAKLEY UNION JOBS-
WHERE THEY ARE. AND WE HAVE A
HUGE NEED FOR CAPPING ORPHAN
WELLS AND REMEDIATING OILFIELDS
HUGE MASSIVE UNMET NEEDS THAT
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH NOW.
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT
COMPLICATED INFRASTRUCTURE
WORK. AND IT SHOULD BE A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
THAT IS DOING THAT WORK BECAUSE
WE IT SHOULD BE SKILLED AND
TRAINED PERIOD THAT'S A GOOD
THING IN TERMS OF. HAVING THE
ABSOLUTE HIGHEST QUALITY WORK-
BUT IT ALSO WILL BE A
TRANSITION. FOR THOSE OIL
WORKERS. BECAUSE THAT WORK
HAPPENS TO BE GEOGRAPHICALLY
NEAR WHERE THE OIL EXTRACTION
IS HAPPENING OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
HE'S OUR PREVIOUS. BILLS SO IT
CAN BE A WIN WIN AND SO I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE. OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IN MOVING
US. TOWARDS A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE AND IS FOR
MEDIATION- EFFORTS. BY QUESTION
THE AUTHOR- IF THE AUTHOR WILL
TAKE THE QUESTION HERE AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS. IS NOT
ABOUT ME QUESTION THE
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE OF THE
BILL- BUT I DO. WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE WORKERS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY DOING THE WORK ARE
GOING OR NOT GOING TO HAPPEN OR
NOT GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOBS-
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE TO. LEAVE
AS WE'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
CONCERNS POTENTIALLY LEAVE A
JOB TO DO AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. TO COME BACK AND I
KNOW HAVING SPOKEN WITH- FOLKS
IN THE BUILDING TRADES WITH THE
AUTHOR THAT IS NOT THE INTENT-
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
INTENT IS TO THAT THERE CAN BE.
A SMOOTH TRANSITION FOR THESE
pBILL RIGHT NOW THE I DON'T I
DON'T SEE THAT. AS AS BEING
CLEARLY OUTLINED IN THE BILL
AND I THINK FOR ME AND FOR A
LOT OF US- WHO WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT THIS BILL IS
DOING- WE WOULD LIKE THAT
INSURANCE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE-
WANT THESE PEOPLE TO BE TREATED
FAIRLY. SO- QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. WE TAKE A QUESTION
CENTERS TURN YES. SEND ARENA-
SO TO THE AUTHORS ARE THROUGH
THE CHAIR- ARE YOU- WILLING. TO
MAKE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY- TO CLARIFY THAT THESE
WORKERS WILL NOT BE FIRED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE THAT CREDIT SHOULD STATUS
AND IT- OR AND THE LAY OUT A
PROCESS. TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
JOBS. THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESENT HERE THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MY COLLECTION SERVICES CO
AND FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE I'M- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE WORK FORCE IMPACTED HERE I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE ACTUAL- THE
EMPLOYEES OF AN OWNER OPERATOR.
SO I THINK THE QUESTION IS
ABOUT- THE CONTRACTORS OR
SUBCONTRACTORS I JUST WANNA BE
CLEAR BECAUSE THE BILL ALREADY
EXPLICITLY EXAMS ALL EMPLOYEES
OF ALL THE OWNER OPERATORS.
IT'S REALLY WHEN THEY CONTRACT
OUT- WHETHER THOSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PREVAILING WAGE. I THINK WE-
WANT TO MAKE SURE I GOT YOUR
QUESTION RIGHT BUT JUST TO DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO- PAGE SIX.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY FOUR I THINK I PAID SIX
SECTION IS NOT APPLIED AT A
CHLOE'S OF AN OWNER OPERATOR
THE WEATHER PRODUCTION FACILITY
OR PREVENT THE OWNER OPERATOR
FROM USING ITS OWN EMPLOYEES TO
PERFORM ANY OF THE WORK THAT
HASN'T BEEN ASSIGNED. TO
CONTRACTORS- BODY PLAYS THE
CONTRACTOR PRESENT AND WORKING-
SO. IF THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SORT OF. THE CONTRACTED OUT
WORK. THE CHALLENGE I HAVE WITH.
I DON'T KNOW QUITE HOW TO
ACHIEVE THE MECHANICS YOU'RE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I DON'T
WANT TO UNDERCUT PREVAILING
WAGE IN ANYWAY HERE- SO. YOU
KNOW. IF THE IF THE IF WE'RE
SAYING WE WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYEES
TO SAY. KEEP THAT JOB THEY HAVE
NOW BUT THEY'RE BEING BEING
PAID SUBSTANDARD WAGES I
WOULDN'T WANT TO TAKE THAT
IMAGE TO ME THAT UNDERCUTS THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL. I THINK.
VIEW THE WAY IN PRACTICE THIS
LEGISLATION THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION IS WORK WE PASSED A
SIMILAR MEASURE IN THE REFINERY
SECTOR- SP FIFTY FOUR I THINK
IT WAS. SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN HERE MAYBE SIX SIX SEVEN
YEARS AGO. THERE'S AN EXPEDITED
TRAINING PROGRAM. THAT- THAT
WAS USED FOR ACCOUNTING BOTH
PASTELS I WORKED IN THE FIELD
AS WELL AS- SORT OF PERCENTAGE
BASIS SO IN PRACTICE IN OTHER
WORDS THE WAY THE INDUSTRY WE
BELIEVE WOULD MANAGE THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS LEGISLATION
WOULD BE THAT ON A CRAFT BASIS
NOT A 100% WOULD HAVE TO
NECESSARILY COMPLETE ALL THE
STANDARD APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT TO YOUR TIMELINE.
OF SORT OF YOU HAVE TO BE FIRED
FROM YOUR JOB AND WAIT I DON'T
THAT TERM IS DOESN'T COMPORT
WITH HOW INDUSTRY PRACTICES IT
HAS BEEN ADMINISTERED- SO I
WOULD. JUST SAY. LOOK AT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS ENACTED
AWAY ANYONE'S JOB. BUT IT IS TO
PUSH THE EMPLOYER'S SPECIALLY
THE CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS TO STEP UP.
INSERTING PREVAILING WAGE SO I
WANT TO JUST CLEAR I MEAN ASK A
QUESTION BACK TO THE QUESTION
BUT I DON'T WANT. THE KIND OF
AMENDMENT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IF YOU WOULD ALLOW. THEN THIS
SORT OF CURRENT PRACTICES TO
CONTINUE I WOULDN'T BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT- BUT IF
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE YOU HAVE
IN MIND AND I'M I'M OPEN.
REGULAR WINNER THANK YOU- AND
SO THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
CHAIR- I FULLY AGREE I DON'T
WANT JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE
HAPPENS TO WORK FOR A
CONTRACTOR INSTEAD OF THE OIL
PRODUCER THAT THEY DON'T GET
THE PREVAILING WAGE IN THERE-
HARMS AS A RESULT. AND I HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH THOSE WORKERS
ALSO BEING TRANSITIONS TO
HAVING YOU KNOW. THAT THOSE ALL
THE SKILLED WORKFORCE
PREVAILING WAGE PROTECTIONS
DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY'RE
WORKING FOR A CONTRACT. BUT THE
QUESTIONS FOR THOSE NUMEROUS
WORKERS WHO ARE WORKING FOR
CONTRACTORS WHAT IS THE PATH
GOING TO BE FOR THEM RIGHT I
I'M AS I MENTIONED ARE NOT
GOING TO. LOSE THEIR JOBS THEY
HAVE TO WE'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS ARE THEY GONNA HAVE TO
GO TO THE BACK OF THE LINE FOR.
APPRENTICESHIPS AND I ANSWER
THE QUESTION THE AUTHOR IS YOU
COULD NOT NOT TO SOMEHOW EXEMPT
THEM SO THEY'RENOT GETTING
PREVAILING WAGE- THE QUESTION
IS WHAT IS. THIS I WOULD WANT
THE BILL TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THE PATHWAY IS. FOR THEM AS
WELL THAT THAT'S MY THAT'S THE
QUESTION OKAY- THAT'S HELPFUL-
G. DEPARTMENT. OF PRISONS IF
YOU DON'T MIND- SO. THEN WALK
BACK THROUGH THE TRANSITION
PROCESS. NOT HERE- SO SKILLED
AND TRAINED PROCESS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT ONLY
REQUIRES A PRINTER SHOULD
GRADUATE IN A PERCENTAGE SAYS
SAY FROM 3260% BY CRAFT SO THE
OTHER. TEN FORTY REMAINING
4270% CAN BE- ANYWAY- IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE SORT OF-
COMPLETE- SKILL AND TRAIN UP
AND DOWN THE RANKS SO IN THEORY
IF THERE WERE SOME OF THESE
FOLKS WHO WERE IN- EXISTING.
BANK WITH EXISTING CONTRACTORS
OR SUBCONTRACTORS BECAUSE A LOT
OF HIS WORK AT SUBCONTRACTED BY
THE WAY- AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DON'T WORK FOR
ANYBODY- AND SORT OF HAVE TO GO
TO JOB TO JOB AS JOURNEYMEN
AND- WOMEN AND MOSTLY NINE TO
BE HONEST- BUT- BUT DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW LONG TERM BENEFITS-
DON'T HAVE THE STABILITY OF A
FULL TIME THING SO. THE ONLY
TIME THE PL THEY REQUIRE APPEAL
LADY S REQUIRED IF THE OWNER
OPERATOR OXEN THIS BILL DOES
NOT MANDATE ANY DELAYS. SO THEY
CAN KIND OF MAKING KEEP
CONTRACTING HOW THEY WANT A
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROCESS. BUT IT
DOESN'T. REQUIRE EVERYONE TO GO
THROUGH IT SO. IF THAT NEEDSBE.
CLARIFIED MORE HELP INDUSTRY
PRACTICE WORKS- I'M I'M HAPPY
TO DO THAT IN SOME KIND OF
FINDING OR- OR AN EXPLANATION
BUT I. I'M JUST I'M I'M- I'M A
LITTLE CAUTIOUS ABOUT- ADAPTING
ITS WHOLESALE AN AMENDMENT THAT.
COULD HAVE- COULD HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR SORT OF
ALLOWING THAT THAT KIND OF
CONTRACTING TO KEEP GOING ON I
THINK THAT THAT DENIGRATES THE
QUALITY OF THE WORK I THINK
IT'S A PROBLEM SO- I CONCERNED
THAT'S AN UNSATISFYING ANSWER
BUT- I THINK THAT IF WE CAN
ARTICULATE MORE THE INDUSTRY
PRACTICE GOING FORWARD AND HOW
THE THERE'S ALREADY CONTRACTUAL
ABILITIES TO DO THIS WORK MAYBE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME SOME-
SOLACE TO FOLKS. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND SENATOR WIENER.
OKAY VERY GOOD SENATOR ALLEN
EUROPE NEXT. MEMBERS I- I
BELIEVE I SUPPOSE YOU KNOW I- I
WILL I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
CONCEPTS- VOTED FOR
INTERMEDIATE- BUT I REALLY DO
SHARE A LOT OF THE CORE
CONCERNS WE JUST RAISED BY THE
CENTER FOR SAN FRANCISCO- I WAS
ABLE TO LISTEN TO THE AUTHOR'S.
ANSWER THERE SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
SOME LEVELS OF COMPLEXITY TO
WHAT I THINK INITIALLY TO MANY
OF US SEEM LIKE A SIMPLE
PROBLEM WHICH IS HOW DO YOU
ENSURE THAT FOLKS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THESE RAKES FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING I HAVEN'T HAD ANY
SAFETY PROBLEMS ARE NOT GOING
TO. BE REALLY I'M JUSTIFIABLY
JAMMED UP BY A BY A BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO LEAVE
WORK OFTEN BE BE TRAINED TO DO
THE VERY WORK THEY'VE BEEN
DOING FOR DECADES- SO I THINK
THE CONCERN IT'S OUT THRE-
AMONGST MANY OF THE MEMBERS IS
HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE DO RIGHT
BY THESE WORKERS THAT HAVE
BEEN. WORKING SO HARD IN THE
FIELD FOR SO LONG WITHOUT ANY
PROBLEMS- WHILE THE SAME TIME
ACHIEVING THE VERY NOBLE-
WORKER PROTECTION LONG TERM
WORKER PROTECTION GOALS THAT I
THINK ARE AT THE HEART OF THIS
BILL SO I. TRIED MY BEST TO
LISTEN TO THE DISCUSSION- IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SOME LAYERS
OF COMPLEXITY HERE I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH- WITH- AND- IT'S- IT'S A
BROADER CONCERNS ABOUT NOT.
DOING ANYTHING THAT MIGHT.
UNDERMINE OUR AS SOME KIND OF
CORPORATE VENTURE CORPORATE
SCHOOLS REALLY KNOWS TO
PREVAILING WAGE ANOTHER.
PROTECTION SO. I'M CERTAIN I
GUESS YET WE GOT A WHOLE DAY
NOW I SUPPOSE TO SEE IF YOU CAN
LAND SOME OF THESE COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AND- I'LL BE WATCHING THIS
DISCUSSION CLOSELY. AND BUT I
DO I DO WANT TO. ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THESE PRODUCTS ARE
IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT. HI AND THROW IN A
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING- IN THESE IN THESE
RATES FOR A LONG TIME UNDER THE
BUS. AS WE'RE DOING RIGHT BY-
BY WORKERS IN THE FUTURE AS WE
AS WE TRY TO PUT THESE
PROTECTIONS YOU'RE LOOKING TO
PUT IN PLACE- IN A LONG TERM.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO SENATOR
NEWMAN PORTENT TINO CALL
MARGARET RUSSELL AND THEN
SENATOR LOAN CENTER NEWMAN THE
PLEASURE CENTER EIGHT WHEN I
GOT YOU. DATE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OF I'LL BE BRIEF I WANT
TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I'M FROM SANTA
MONICA. I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD-
FOR HER DILIGENT- AND
RELENTLESS WORK ON BEHALF OF
HER CONSTITUENTS. THAT IS DOING
HIS JOB EXACTLY HOW IT SHOULD
BE DONE. SHE HAS BEEN
ACCESSIBLE AND REASONABLE SHE'S
CONNECTED US- TERROR
CONSTITUENTS WE'VE ALL HAD A
NUMBER OF REALLY INTERESTING
AND CONCERNING CONVERSATIONS.
AS IT RELATES TO THEIR LIVES.
AND THE JEOPARDY THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES APPARENTLY UNDER AND
SO WITH THAT. I WOULD URGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION. BOTH WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES BUT THROUGH AT THE
CENTER FROM BAKERSFIELD- AND
LET'S FIND A SOLUTION. THAT
DOES NOT PUT THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF FRESH OUT. OF- KERN COUNTY
AND ELSEWHERE. OUT OF WORK FOR
REALLY NO REASON AT ALL OTHER
THAN. A LACK OF DILIGENCE ON
OUR PART THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER PORTENT
TINA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I'M RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR NINETEEN AND I ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY THAT- THIS
IS BEEN A VERY HEALTHY DEBATE-
I HAVE FAITH IN IN THE AUTHOR
AND THE GOAL OF THE BILL TO
BRING- BETTER STANDARDS AND
WORKER PROTECTIONS. TO AN
INDUSTRY- AND SO I I'M GOING
SUPPORTED TODAY AND- THINK THE
ROBUST DEBATES HEALTHY AND- ONE
WANTED TO CONTINUE SO I THINK
IT SHOULD GE OUT OF THIS HOUSE
OF THAT CONVERSATION CAN
CONTINUE THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTENT TINO CENTER COM LONGER.
SENATOR COM LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT YOU KNOW- YOU
COME TO THE FLOOR AND YOU THINK
SOMEONE'S GONNA YOU KNOW GOING
TO GO DOWN ROUTE EIGHTY AND YOU
END UP ON RUBY- AS I WAS
LISTENING TO. THE DISCUSSION ON
THIS BILL IT MADE ME THINK
ABOUT. V. NUMEROUS CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS HAPPENING. IN MY
DISTRICT. WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS ROBUST DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE
A DIVERSE WORK FORCE. AND
INVARIABLY IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WE ARE TOLD WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH AFRICAN AMERICAN WORKERS
WHO ARE APPRENTICES HE CAN BE
ON THIS CONSTRUCTION SITE. AND
SO THE FEW THAT YOU SEE ARE THE
ONES HOLDING THE STOP SIGNS.
NOT REALLY FULLY BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN APPRENTICE OR
JOURNEYMAN EXPERIENCE TO GET
THE KIND OF TRAINING THAT THEY
NEED. NOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
UNIONS- IN LA THAT ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD ON THIS AND GREAT
PARTNERSHIPS. I WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT BUT THAT IS A CONCERN
SO AS I WAS LISTENING TO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THAT. AND WHAT
WE HAVE ALSO. LEARNED AND SEEN.
IS THAT WHEN THEY ARE UNABLE TO
GET THE WORK FORCE THAT THEY
NEED. THEY IMPORT THE TRAINED
WORKERS. FROM OTHER STATES TO
COME ON TO THE JOB SITES TO
COMPLETE THE WORK. WORDING
UNION. WORKERS BUT THEY ARE NOT
COMING FROM OUR CALIFORNIA
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND SO THIS MAY
BE A QUESTION FOR THAT- THE
AUTHORS TO THE CHAIR OR MAYBE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
ADDRESS BUT I TOO AM CONCERNED
THAT WE ARE- UNKNOWINGLY OR
UNWITTINGLY OPENING UP AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BLACK AND BROWN
FOLKS WHO CURRENTLY WORK THESE
JOBS- TO BE FOR WHATEVER REASON
SHIFTED OFF OF THEM- BECAUSE OF
THE GOOD INTENTION OF THE BILL
AND THEN ALLOWING OTHER FOLKS
TO COME INTO OUR STATE TO GRAB
THOSE JOBS BECAUSE THEY ARE
JUST NOT ENOUGH OF X. KIND OF
WORKER. OR B. KIND OF WORKER
WHO IS APPROPRIATELY AND
ADEQUATELY TRAINED TO PERFORM
THESE JOBS I KNOW THAT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE DIFFERENT
ACROSS THE STATE SO I AM ONLY
SPEAKING ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE IN
LOS ANGELES- BUT THIS IS A
CONCERN I HAVE THE OIL FIELD IN
MY DISTRICT MY DISTRICT IS. A
FEROCIOUSLY TRYING TO CLOSE IT
THE REALITY IS MOST OF THE
FOLKS THAT WORK AT THAT SITE
OUR BLACK AND BROWN. BEEN ABLE
TO PUT THEIR KIDS THROUGH
COLLEGE AND THEIR GRANDKIDS
THROUGH COLLEGE WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR SITE. I WOULD HATE
TO WAKE UP- HEY AND SEE THAT
WE'RE NOT WALKING THE WALK
AROUND JUST TRANSITION BUT B. I
WOULD HATE TO WAKE UP AND SEE
THAT ALL OF THOSE FOLKS THAT
WORK THERE. HAVE NOW BEEN
REPLACED BY OTHER FOLKS THAT
DON'T LOOK LIKE THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH THEY WORK SO MAYBE
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT IS REALLY
LEGITIMATE. YOU KNOW THE SUBS.
AND THE SUBS THEY'RE LOOKING TO
FINISH THE JOB. THEY DON'T CARE
WHO THE PERSON IS. DIVERSITY BE
SO IF WE ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE CREATING
DIVERSITY IN A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO BE REALISTIC
ABOUT HOW SUBS MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY'RE ASKED
TO MEET WHICHIS TO HAVE FOLKS
ON THESE JOBS THAT KNOW HOW TO
DO THE JOB AND ARE TRYING TO DO
THE JOB- AND THAT MAY. REALLY
PUSHES SO MANY OF OUR PEOPLE
OUT OF THOSE JOBS IN ONTO THE
YOU KNOW EDT ROLES WHERE WE
KNOW THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO GET
PHONES ANSWERED AND CLAIMS
APPROVED THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER CALM WATER AND SINISTER
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS THOSE
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS IN YOUR
CLOTHES WE'RE NOW GOING TO
CENTRE TORONTO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VENTURE- I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS. HAS MOVED THE INTO AN
ISSUE ABOUT WORKERS GETTING
FIRED I UNDERSTAND THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND THIS AND I'VE LIVED
WITH THIS AND WORKED IN AND-
THROUGH THE LABOR MOVEMENT-
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES ON
THIS FOR A LONG TIME MANY MANY
YEARS. AND WE HAVE ADDRESSED
WITH DRESSED IN A VERY SERIOUS
WAY A LOT OF THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
INCLUDING. THE HIRING FROM
WHERE LOCAL HIRE- THE NUMBERS
OF LOCAL HIRE ALL OF THAT. BUT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT TO ME IS A
STANDARD. THAT WE AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SETTING AND
REINFORCING AND SUPPORTING IT'S
ABOUT A STANDARD. AND EVERY
COMPANY CONTRACTOR
SUBCONTRACTOR THAT GETS HIRED
BY THE MAIN OWNER OPERATOR
EMPLOYER COMPANY. THAT THEY
HAVE TO FULFILL THAT STANDARD
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT A STANDARD OF WHAT
TRAINING THEY'RE GOING TO GET.
A QUALITY TRAINING. THAT IT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT SAFETY
SERIOUSLY TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
SAFETY- WHAT THEIR WAGES ARE
GOING TO BE WHAT THEIR BENEFITS
ARE GOING TO BE. ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT'S THE STANDARD
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HEREWITH
THIS BILL IT'S NOT ABOUT FIRING
WORKERS. AND THIS IS B. COM HAS
BEEN CHANGED INTO A WHOLE
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION HERE AS
A WAY TO GET OVER TO GET TO GET
AWAY FROM THE CORE ISSUE. THIS
IS THE CORE ISSUE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE EVERY EMPLOYER
FROM THE TOP TO THE MIDDLE TO
THE BOTTOM EVERY EMPLOYER MEET
A HIGH QUALITY STANDARD. AND WE
WANT THAT NOT FOR ANYTHING ELSE
OTHER THAN FOR THE GOOD OF
THOSE WORKERS THAT THOSE
WORKERS KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO GET THAT KIND OF TRAINING
WHEN THEY GET THAT QUALITY
TRAINING. THEY'RE CERTIFIED AND
THEY CAN WORK ON THESE PROJECTS
AND THEY'LL GET PAID WHAT THEY
DESERVE SO I REALLY YOU KNOW
HOW THIS IS BEEN TWISTED INTO
WORKERS ARE GOING TO GET FIRED.
IT'S A REALLY SMART WAY OF
DISTRACTING FROM THE CORE ISSUE
HERE THE CORE ISSUE IS SKILLED
TRAINED WORKERS. AND THE
ABILITY TO. PUT THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN TO WORK. ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES I AGREE WITH I WORKED
REALLY HARD ON THAT WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES OVER MANY
YEARS. THE DONE AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB OF. CHANGING
THE CULTURE TO HIRE MORE PEOPLE
OF COLOR RECRUIT MORE WOMEN ARE
RECRUITED FROM THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED YOU NAME IT EVERY
GROUP THAT HAS BEEN X. IS
ACTIVELY BEING RECRUITED. I'VE
SEEN IT I'VE GONE TO THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THE
ACTUAL TRAINING PROGRAMS I WAS
JUST IN FRESNO A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO DURING THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL CONSTRUCTION SITES. SO YOU
KNOW LET'S LET'S JUST FOCUS ON
WHAT THIS IS TRYING TO DO AND
THAT IS A QUALITY STANDARD OF
LIVING AND WORKING. FOR THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO SENATOR LAMONT.
CALLING I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S HAPPENING
AND I THINK YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
TALKED A LOT ABOUT A HIGH
QUALITY STANDARD AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS- IN IN I
THINK OF THE FACT THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION TWO
DAYS. THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE
VEHICLE THAT'S ALLOWED FOR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS
LEGISLATIVE INPUT AND
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW. AND I ALSO
THINK OF THE FACT THAT THOSE
WHO ARE SUPPORTING- THIS
PROCESS- HAVE YOU NOR
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THIS BILL
BUT HAVE NOT ALLOWED THAT
CONVERSATION FOR OTHER BILLS.
AND I WONDER YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE IF WE WERE ABLE
TO HAVE A TRUE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT ALL OF THIS NEEDS.
TO BE ALL ENERGY JOBS NOT JUST
TO THE OIL INDUSTRY WE HAVE A
LIMITED OURSELVES NOT JUST IN
THIS HOUSE BUT IN THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOWING THOSE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS TO
HAPPEN. I HAVE HEARD COLLEAGUES
TODAY SAY I AM HAPPY THAT THIS
ROBUST CONVERSATION IS
HAPPENING WHAT ABOUT FOR OTHER
SECTORS. THESE ARE ALL VALID
POINTS. WAGES. SAFETY STANDARD.
IMPORTERS LOCAL HIRE WHERE ARE
THOSE OTHER CONVERSATIONS AND I
HOPE THAT AS THIS BILL
POTENTIALLY MOVES FORWARD IT
HIGHLIGHTS HOW MUCH THESE
CONVERSATIONS CAN FEED INTO AN
OUTCOME THAT HELPS EVERYONE AND
I THINK THAT AS I'VE HEARD
COLLEAGUES AND YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD-
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS ON THE SAME
SIDE OF ENERGY BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANS TO THE EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIAN AND HOW WE
TRANSITION THOSE THAT ARE
ALREADY WORKING IN THIS SPACE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE PART OF
A UNION. THAT'S A GOOD THING
FOR THOSE OF US WHO BELIEVE IN
THAT AND SO I THINK THAT THIS
ISN'T YOU KNOW IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL HAS
GENERATED A NEEDED CONVERSATION
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE COMMENTS
THAT ARE BEING MADE ARE NOT
SIMPLY LIMITED TO IT SHOULD NOT
IN MY OPINION BE SIMPLY LIMITED
TO THIS SOURCE OF ENERGY THERE
ARE MANY ENERGY JOBS OUT THERE
THAT NEED THIS CONVERSATION-
AND SO I HOPE THAT IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD TODAY- WE DON'T
LIMIT OURSELVES TO THIS I HOPE
THERE'S A COMMITMENT FROM.
EVERYONE INVOLVED BOTH
SUPPORTERS AND THOSE THAT FEEL
THAT THIS BILL MAY HAVE
LIMITATIONS TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS AND
SOLVE FOR A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
AND ISSUES. THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
CENTER LAMONT SENATOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS IT HAS BEEN A VERY
INTERESTING CONVERSATION. AND I
WILL SAY I WAS SITTING NEXT TO
THE SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD
DURING COMMITTEE WHEN HIS BILL
CAME THROUGH AND I HAVE
CERTAINLY FELT AND HEARD HER
PASSION ON THIS TOPIC- ALSO
THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT AREAS
AND IN A SPECIALLY IN THE
VALLEY AND IN THE CENTER FROM
BAKERSFIELD HER HER CAN HURT
THE- ECONOMY IS MOSTLY AG AND
AN OIL MADE UP THAT IS. THAT IS
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE
ECONOMY AND LET'S NOT BE LET'S
NOT KID OURSELVES BOTH OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES ARE OFTEN UNDER
ATTACK IN THIS HOUSE SUCH I
MEAN IT'S JUST THE NATURE I
THINK OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE
OPERATE. AND I'M AND WE ALL
BELIEVE IN A IN A AT PEOPLE
BEING PAID A DECENT WAGE WE ALL
BELIEVE THOSE THINGS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT DRESS THAT JUST
TRANSITION FOR ALL WORKERS- I
HAVE ALSO TALKED TO THOSE
WORKERS AND THEY ARE MAJORITY
BLACK AND BROWN WHO LIVE IN
THAT AREA. OF FOLKS IN AREAS
LIKE WE REPRESENT THAT
OFTENTIMES THEY GO IN THE
MILITARY OR THE PRISON
SOMETIMES BOTH AND WHEN THEY
COME BACK TO FAMILIES ARE THERE
AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A LIVING SO I WOULD
CERTAINLY ASK THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING TO DISPLACE THOSE
WORKERS BUT HELP PEOPLE COME
ALONG AND NOT TO ME WE CAN TALK
ABOUT WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
ACHIEVE A STANDARD. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS IN
THIS BUILDING ABOUT EQUITY AND
EQUALITY AND SOMETIMES THAT
THOSE ARE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
SOMETIMES THERE IS A LOT BIGGER
BRIDGE- THAT FOLKS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE SAME PLACE-
AND RUSHING TO DO THAT I THINK
THE LAST THING WE WANT TO DO.
IS UPSET AND ECONOMY AND THAT
HAS CREATED A MIDDLE CLASS LIFE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE
TO OWN THEIR HOME SEND THEIR
KIDS TO COLLEGE THOSE ARE THE
EXACT KIND OF THINGS WE WANT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
OF GENERATIONAL WEALTH IN THIS
HOUSE RIGHT WE ALSO TALK ABOUT
ABILITY TO OWN A HOME IN THE
PAST. THAT ON YOUR KID THAT'S
WHAT A LOT OF THESE WERE OCCURS
IN THE BIGGEST CURRENT- WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO. AND SO AS WE
RUSSIAN AND LET'S NOT PRETEND
THE BUILDING TRADES DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF. POWER IN THIS ROOM IN
THIS BUILDING OKAY. AND LET'S
NOT PRETEND LIKE THIS THIS BILL
IS NOT HELPFUL FOR THEM ALL
RIGHT THAT'S THAT THAT IS JUST
WHAT IT IS. SO THE SAME TIME WE
WANT TO HELP THEM WE WANT
EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO BE
PROTECTED. IF THEY CHOOSE TO BE
AND YOU NEED TO BE IN THE
UNION. BUT LET'S NOT PRETEND
AND LET HIS BLOOD IS TO BE VERY
HONEST ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE OTHER SIDE AND
THEN COME BACK OVER HERE. THAT
I THINK WE ARE VERY SERIOUS AND
MY- CALLING FROM SANTA BARBARA
MAKES THIS POINT TOO. ABOUT HOW
DO WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT NOT LEAVING EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE WORKING IN
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS IN THEIR
AREA THERE ARE LOCAL. AND THEN
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DISPLACE
THEM. BY SOME OF OUR LARGER.
GOOD GOALS RIGHT THE GOOD GIRLS
WHO WANT TO DO BUT LET'S NOT
LEAVE PEOPLE BEHIND I THINK
THAT HOPEFULLY IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT. THAT'S
WHAT WE TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN
IN TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN OTHER
SECTORS AND IN OTHER AREAS THAT
WE LIKE TO WORK IN. LET'S DO
THE SAME WHILE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE. THE
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD WHO
COMMUNICATES WITH PASSION. AND
FAX AND IN A REAL HEART FOR HER
ONSTITUENCY. AND ALL FORTY OF
OUR VOICES SHOULD MATTER IN
THIS ROOM. AND ALL FORTY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE REPRESENT.
ALSO SHOULD HAVE THE
REPRESENTATION. THAT IS.
PROMISED TO US IN THIS
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY. THANK
YOU CENTER EDMUNDSON. BETTER
PRESENT MEMBERS- AGAIN I WAS
NOT GOING TO GET UP AND SPEAK
ON THIS BILL AND I'VE HEARD
THIS DIALOGUE. WHICH HAS BEEN A
ROBUST AND FOR MY GOOD- CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES HERE I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE DO
HAVE HIGH QUALITY STANDARDS.
FOR LABOR IN THE STATE BUT
WORDS ON A BILL MATTER. WORDS
ON A BILL MATTER AND FOR MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND SANTA MONICA I
APPRECIATE THE WAY THEY FRAMED
THEIR DEBATE I'M NOT GOING TO
REPEAT IT I THINK THESE ARE
GREAT UNION JOBS NOBODY
SUGGESTING THAT EVEN ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE I WILL NOT BE
UNIONIZED MEMBERS BUT THERE
NEEDS TO BE. SOME OPPORTUNITY
FOR- I DON'T EVEN THINK
GRANDFATHER IS AN APPROPRIATE
WORD I THINK TRANSITION. THERE
NEEDS TO BE A TRANSITION PLAN
THERE NEEDS TO BE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL I'VE TALKED TO THE
BUILDING TRADES MYSELF. IT FOR-
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL FROM LOS
ANGELES WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
YOU'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS ISSUE
ALL WEEK AND LAST WEEK AS WELL
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO AMEND
THIS BILL. DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
AND WE'RE NOT THERE SO I WOULD
ASK LIKE TO ASK THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES ONE FINAL
QUESTION OR- SINISTER WE TAKE A
QUESTION SURE YES FOR SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS. ARE YOU
WILLING TO MAKE CLEAR. THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
TRANSITION PLAN SO EMPLOYEES.
ARE NOT MOVES ARE NOT MOVED OUT
OF THEIR JOBS. FUEL FOR THE FOR
ANY TYPE OF TRAINING I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR I JUST DON'T WANT
THESE PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
I THINK THAT'S QUITE CLEAR THE
THIRTY TO SIXTY. WHAT AND THEN
ONE FINAL POINT TO THE CENTER.
THE 3260% YOU SAY. IF THERE IS
A PERCENTAGE THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE FROM DIFFERENT FROM
DIFFERENT CONTRACTORS. THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THAT. IS
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. SO THIS BILL PASSES. AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THIS BILL
LET'S JUST SAY IT AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE LIKE TWO OR
THREE MONTHS TO DO THAT THAT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH TIME SO ARE YOU
WILLING TO DO TO WORK IN THIS
BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE WRONGS IN
WRITING IN THE BILL ARE RIGHT
INTO THE SATISFACTION OF A LOT
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
FLOOR. SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MY COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA AND I
APPRECIATE THE FRUSTRATION AND
I HAVE BEEN- WELL BRIEFED ON.
ON THE CONCERNS. I DO THINK
FACTS MATTER I THINK WORDS AN
APPEAL MATTER. FOR A LOT OF.
ACCOLADES GIVEN FOR FACTS SO I
FIGURED THAT THAT SPIRIT.
APPOINTEE TO THE TRANSITION
PLAN IN THE BILL- THOSE WHO
WANT TO DIG INTO THE DETAILS
HERE. AS OF JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TO. 70% OF THE
WORK FORCE CAN REMAIN AS IS. NO
ONE IS GETTING FIRED ON DAY ONE.
THAT'S A RED HERRING. SO I KNOW
WE'VE ESTABLISHED THAT IT'S
SOME KIND OF PREMISE OF THE
BILL AND PEOPLE HAVE BESTED
INTERESTS IN THESE KINDS OF
EXISTING CONTRACTING
RELATIONSHIPS CONTINUING. 70%
OF THE WORKFORCE CAN'T CONTINUE.
FOR THE REMAINING 30% LET'S BE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IT'S NOT GOING THROUGH
SKILLED AND TRAINED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM RIGHT
AWAY I. THE DEFINITION. OF
SKILL JOURNEY PERSON IS
IMPORTANT UNDERSTANDING. YOU
CAN EITHER BE IN SKILLS AND
TRAINING AND APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. YOUR JOURNEY PERSONS
THIS IS FOR THE REMAINING 30%
NOT THE SEVENTY YOU CAN BE
ANYONE EXISTING EMPLOYEES BUT
THAT REMAINING THIRTY. THAT
REMAINING THIRTY. AS TO EITHER
BE SKILLED AND TRAINED. OR IS A
SKILL JOURNEY PERS AND ENTER
ANY PERSON UNDER THE BILL SAYS.
CAN JUST HAVE IT AT LEAST AS
MANY HOURS OF ON THE JOB
EXPERIENCE IN THE APPLICABLE
OCCUPATION. SO. EIGHT AM I MEAN
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERN BUT I
THINK WE'VE GOT TO GET A COMMON
PREMISE HERE ABOUT HOW THE BILL
WORKS. IF YOU CUT EVERYONE OFF
ON DAY ONE. AGAIN MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF THE WORK FORCE DOES
NOT EVEN HAVE TO BE A SKILL
JOURNEY PERSON DOES NOT APPEAR
TO BE PAID PREVAILING WAGE
RIGHT AWAY. THAT IS THE
TRANSITION THEN IN TWENTY THREE
THAT GOES UP TO FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. AND TWENTY FOURTH
CLOSE 260% SO I FEEL LIKE WE'VE
GOT A- GROUNDED. SOME OF OUR
CONVERSATION IN IN THE WORDS OF
THE BILL. HERE IF FOR SOME
REASON. THOSE PERCENTAGES IF
FOLKS WANT TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TARGET. IF THERE'S SOME.
YOU KNOW- YOU ANT TO STEER
STEP OF FORTY FIVE OKAY MAKE IT
FORTY PERCENT. WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT BUT- THERE IS A
TRANSITION PLAN IN THIS BILL
LET'S BE CLEAR ON WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON HERE- SO I JUST. I
APPRECIATE THE FRUSTRATION BUT
I THINK WE'VE WE'VE GOT A- SOME
SOME MISTAKES IN OUR PREMISES
ABOUT HOW THIS BILL FUNCTIONS-
IT DOESN'T FORCE UNIONIZATION.
BUT WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE. THANK WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IN
THESE THESE PROFESSIONS
ACTUALLY TWENTY UNION COULD
TURN A PRESSURE COOKER WE'RE BY
THE WAY 75% OF PEOPLE ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND THEN IT IS
A PRETTY PROGRAMS HAVE TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WHEN I CAN IMPORT
A BUNCH OF TEXAS WORKERS LIKE
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW READ A
PRESS. RELEASE ON. WELL THAT
LET'S UNDERSTAND FINISH AND I.
HAVEN'T HAD IT HAS RECEDED SO
MY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WOULD
BE. YOU'VE GOT A TRANSITION
BUILT IN YOU CAN TRANSITION
DURING THE BILL RIGHT NOW YOU
DON'T WANT 70% TO BE JOURNEY
PERSONS HERS OR PREMISES BUTTON
HOW MUCH. I FEEL LIKE 70% IS A
LOT TO OFFER TO KEEP DOING THE
GRANDFATHER IN 70% OF THE
WORKFORCE SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
GOOD OFFER- SO I JUST I GOT TO
GET A LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC AND
I HATE TO DRILL DOWN. SORRY TO
USE THE- PUT IN THERE BUT- I
GOT IT GOT TO DRILL DOWN THE
DETAILS HERE BECAUSE- IT.
OPENED UP PAGE FIVE OF THE BILL
AND IT'S SITTING RIGHT THERE.
SPIKE THAT WAS SICK ARE YOU
DENSE ANDERSON WITH RAM YES
OKAY SENATOR DODD- I'M
QUESTION. I APPRECIATE THE
CENTERS FOR. PROMOTES ANGELUS
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO ANSWER MY YES
OR NO QUESTION. AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT CENTER STERN. ON
DAY ONE. 30% OF THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE SKILLED. AND
TRAINED. AND SO THAT IS THE
BASIC PREMISE. OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES CONCERNS OUR PREMISE
IS NOT THAT THEY ALL SHOULD BE
AT SOME POINT IN TIME. SKILLED
AND TRAINED. MEMBERS OF THE
UNION. THAT'S A HUNDRED
PERCENT. THAT IS IMPORTANT I
THINK TO MOST OF THEM IF NOT
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM HIGH
QUALITY TRAINING HIGH QUALITY
JOBS LIVING WAGES. AND
RETIREMENT FOR SECURITY DOWN
THE LINE. I HAVE NOT GOTTEN THE
ANSWER I NEEDED I WILLNOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND- I
HAVE SPENT THE BETTER PART OF
THE LAST TWO HOURS
INVESTIGATING THE SPILL AND
SPEAKING OF BOTH SIDES IN TERMS
OF HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED. AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS ON. SAFETY ISSUES
RELATED TO CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS DATING BACK TO- MY
YEARS IN THE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
WE HAD AN INCIDENT THAT CALLED
IT BECAUSE IN ELECTRIC. FUSION
AND DEATH. OF A OF A PERSON
USING SENDING US TRANSIT SYSTEM
BECAUSE- A BUS STOP WAS BUILT
WITH A DEFECT THAT CREATED. A
HAZARD THAT KILLED SOMEBODY AND
WE RESPONDED BY THAT. SO I WANT
TO DIRECT MY COMMENTS TO THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE FENCE ON THIS AND I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS BECAUSE I.
INITIALLY STARTED TODAY SHARING
THOSE CONCERNS AND I THOUGHT-
MAYBE THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE
WORKED ON BUT I WAS REMINDED OF
ALL THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE IN
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS AND
SPECIFICALLY. MEMBERS WE'VE
DONE THIS ALREADY. AND WE HAVE
ALREADY VOTED ON BILLS. THAT
SHARE THIS EXACT SAME LANGUAGE
ONE WAS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN SP
FIFTY FOUR. THAT WAS A SAFETY
RELATED ISSUE. IT DIDN'T APPLY
TO THESE WORKERS IN PARTICULAR
SO THIS BILL WOULD BASICALLY
FOLD- THOSE WORKERS INTO THE
SAME PROGRAM UNDER THE EXACT
SAME PROCESS. THE WAY THAT BILL
WAS- SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR PUT
INTO OPERATION. MEMBERS NOT ONE
WORKER WAS DISPLACED. NOT ONE
WORKER WAS DISPLACED UNDER THAT
BILL. AND IF THINGS ARE DONE.
IDENTICAL TO THAT BILL WHICH I
BELIEVE THEY WILL. NOT ONE
WORKER WILL BE DISPLACED UNDER
THE UNDER THIS BILL. SO I JUST
WANT TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMENTS. WHEN WE SAY LET'S NOT
PRETEND THE BUILDING TRADES ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM THIS I'M
ALSO WANT TO REMIND. MEMBERS OF
THIS FLORIDA LET'S LET'S ALSO
NOT PRETEND THAT THE STATE
HASN'T BENEFITED. FROM BETTER
TRAINED WORKERS FROM BETTER
PAID WORKERS FROM HAVING PEOPLE
ON THE JOB THAT YOU KNOW
PRECISELY WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
IN THE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
SKILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE THE
INCIDENCE. OF- OF ACCIDENTS
HAVE GONE DRASTICALLY DOWN. AND
OFTENTIMES THOSE ARE BEING
TOUTED AS- THE- THE RESULT OF
THE INDUSTRY AND REALLY IT'S A
RESULT OF BETTER TRAINING
PROGRAMS SO. I WANT TO. I CAME
IN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL I KNOW A LOT OF YOU HAVE
BEEN I. HAVE DONE MY RESEARCH
AND FOUND THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO MEMBERS TODAY
CAST YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB FOUR ONE NINE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO NO ONE WILL BE
DISPLACED WILL HAVE A BETTER
TRAINED WORKFORCE. AND THEY'LL
BE A BETTER PROCESS AND IT
DOESN'T. PREVENT WORKERS THAT
ARE- NONUNION ACCESS A NON
UNION TRAINING PROGRAM BECAUSE
IT DOES HAVE BEEN CREATED IN
THE PAST THOSE EXIST CURRENTLY.
AND IF THERE ARE ANY SHORTFALLS
THOSE CAN BE. A SHORT UP IN THE
NEXT FEW. MONTHS AND IT DOESN'T
TAKE. LONG TO- GET THESE
PROGRAMS IN OPERATION BUT WE
HAVE THEM ALREADY EXISTING. AND
MEMBERS OF THE BILL DOESN'T
NEED AMENDMENTS- IF YOU WANT
INVESTIGATE SP FIFTY FOUR
SENATORS IF YOU WANT
INVESTIGATORS B. FIFTY FOUR
IT'S THERE IF YOU WANT TO LOOK
INTO THE PROCESS OF SB FIFTY
FOUR. IT'S VERY TRANSPARENT NO
MEMBERS. LOST THEIR JOBS IN THE
COUNTRY. THE SAME PEOPLE WERE
BETTER TRAINED AND ENDED UP
WITH BETTER WAGES AND ISN'T
THAT WE WANT WHAT WE WANT WE
RUN FOR THESE OFFICES PROMISING
A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
BETTER SAFETY AND IN A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THIS BILL WILL
GET US THERE I RECOMMEND I
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
CENTER GROVE WE FORGET YOU ALSO
MAKE SURE CENTER BASE IF YOU
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE UP. PLEASE
PROCEED. HI I NEED TO TAKE
MYSELF AND HOPEFULLY THE REST
OF YOU BACK TO THE BASIC
PREMISE OF THE BILL IT'S ABOUT
SAFETY IN OUR GOOD SENATOR FROM
CURRENT COUNTY GAVE A LITANY OF
STATISTICS FOR THE SAFETY OF
THIS INDUSTRY AS COMPARED TO
MANY OTHERS I'M NOT SURE OF THE
SB FIFTY FOUR AND THAT WAS
CONTAINED IN THAT BILL THAT
THERE WAS LIKE A REAL ISSUE
WITH THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE BEING HARMED ON THAT
JOB. SO THAT DOESN'T REGISTER
WITH ME WHAT REGISTERS WITH ME
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF WE
HAVE BEEN CAUGHT TALKING ABOUT
SCIENCE AND DATA WITH REGARDS
TO THE PANDEMIC WE ALL WANTED
TO HEAR THAT WE NEEDED THAT TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THE THINGS THAT
WERE EING IMPOSED ON US BY THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS WERE TERRIBLE
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE
STATISTICS THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM KERN COUNTY DID AN AMAZING
JOB ON THIS FLOOR TO BRING US
THE FINANCE IN THE STATISTICS
OF THIRTY YEARS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WORKING IN THE OIL
FIELDS WITH THE LOWEST SAFETY
RECORD OF ALL THE OTHER
INDUSTRIES. THAT WERE
COMPARABLE THAT SHOULD MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE WE'VE GOT A BILL
HERE THAT IS A SOLUTION LOOKING
FOR A PROBLEM THAT SHOULD NOT
BE THE JOB OF THE SENATE TO
CREATE PROBLEMS WHERE THEY DO
NOT EXIST SO I URGE YOU TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT LOOK AT WHAT SHE
PRESENTED AN- OUR IN THIS
DISCUSSION IF THERE'S ANYTHING
MISSING IT IS A TRUE ON THE
BOOKS TRANSITION THAT SHOULD BE
PROVIDED IT SHOULD BE
PROSPECTIVE NOT RETROACTIVE SO
WE'RE SAVING SEVENTY PERCENT.
30% ARE BEING PUT OUT TO DO
SOMETHING THEY DON'T NEED TO DO
THE NEW WORKERS COMING OUT OF
SCHOOLS COLLEGES PRISONS ALL OF
THE AREAS THAT SHE MENTIONED
THAT WE'RE GETTING WORKERS YES
THEY MIGHT NEED SOMETHING A
LITTLE HIGHER THIS IS CURRENTLY
THERE BECAUSE THERE'S GOING TO
BE NEW TECHNOLOGY BUT FOR THOSE
1100% WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE
FIELD. FOR ALL THESE YEARS AND
DOING IT RIGHT. PERHAPS THEY
SHOULD THE TRADE. I A NO VOTE.
ON THE TRANSITION IS CLEAR. AND
NOT SUBJECT TO ANY SORT OF
MISINTERPRETATION WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE INTENT OF THESE BILLS
THAT WE PUT OFF THIS FLOOR
OFTEN CHANGE WHEN THEY GET TO
THE REGULATORY AGENCIES PRIOR
TO NOVO. CENTER A BAIT SENATOR
GROVE AND THEN SENT HER TALKING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO DO A LITTLE
CROSS DEBATE HERE AGAIN THINKS
THE AUTHOR FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
LISTENING AND CREATING A
DEBATE- THE US- THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
AND FRIEND THE- SANTA BARBARA I
DO AGREE THAT DEBATE NEEDS TO
TAKE PLACE OFTEN WE PASS BILLS
OFFER THIS FLOOR THAT. YOU KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE THE GENERAL
KNOWLEDGE OF THE BILLS I'M NOT
SAYING I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
I'M LIKE I'LL READ EVERY BILL.
AND I GOT UP HERE AND IT TOOK
ME ABOUT TEN DAYS TO REALIZE
THAT'S COMPLETELY IMPOSSIBLE.
SO AND I THINK THAT THE
VIGOROUS DEBATE IS IMPORTANT
AND IT DOES ADDRESS ISSUES I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS A FEW THINGS.
MY COLLEAGUE I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES AND WHO I KNOW HER
HEART AND PASSION. IS AN
ACTIVIST FOR THE LABOR INDUSTRY
HAS- BROUGHT HER HERE TO THIS
SENATE. WITH A BACKGROUND THAT
IS DIFFERENT THAN MINE I KNOW
THAT AND WE'RE ALL. PRODUCTS OF
OUR ENVIRONMENT IN THE SPHERE
OF INFLUENCE THAT WE ARE AROUND
AND THE I THINK LIKE THAT SOME
PEOPLE SAID WORDS MATTER IN
WORDS MATTER. AT NO TIME IN ANY
WAY DID I SAY THAT THESE
EMPLOYEES WOULD BE FIRED THEY
WILL NOT BE FIRED. THE ISSUE IS
IN THE BILL ON PAGE FIVE AND IT
SAYS IT STARTS ON PAGE FOUR AT
THE BOTTOM LINE THIRTY EIGHT IT
SAYS THAT THEY WILL BE SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE WHICH
MEANS A WORK FORCE THAT BOTH
MEETS THE FOLLOWING CRITERIA
ONE. ALL WORKERS WILL EITHER BE
REGISTERED APPRENTICES OR
SKILLED JOURNEY PERSONS. TO AS
OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
AT LEAST 30% OF THE JOURNEY
LEVEL GRADUATE SCHOOL DRESSES
SECOND. THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE
BILL IS THE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT CURRENTLY LIKE I
SAID- 55% PEOPLE OF COLOR WE'RE
MIXING KERN COUNTY WE HAVE
BLACK BROWN TEN JABI- CAUCASIAN
WE HAVE. IT WE HAVE SO MANY
DIVERSE PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT ARE EMPLOYED IN THIS
INDUSTRY THAT GIVES PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED. I'M
TALKING YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE IF YOU
WERE WILLING TO SHOW UP AND
LEARN THEY WILL TEACH YOU A
SKILL ON A TRADE THAT YOU COULD
ADVANCE. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THESE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
WORKERS ON LIKE I SAID PAGE
FIVE LINE ITEM ONE. ALL IT DOES
IT SAY SOME IT SAYS ALL
WORKERS. WILL BE APPRENTICES
FOR RICHARD PRODUCER JOURNEY
LEVEL THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE TRAINING. THE
TRAINING THAT'S OFFERED BY
THESE UNIONS WHICH IS GOOD I
HAVE FAITH ALL RIGHT AND IF
SOMEBODY CAN HELP EDUCATE ME ON
THIS ALSO. I HAVE DILIGENTLY
RESEARCHED GOT THE DATA BUT I
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO FOUND
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT IS
OFFERED. AND BY THE LABOR
UNIONS THAT ADDRESS THE OIL
INDUSTRY TRAINING PROGRAMS I
FOUND ONE IT'S WITH ABC THAT
WAS STARTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHICH IS CREATED EIGHT. A
SAFE WORK FORCE BASED ON THE
DATA THE LABOR STANDARDS IS
SIXTY SIX THAT I. ADDRESSED
EARLIER IN MY BILL I LIKE TO
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA
FOR BRINGING IN A VERY VERY
GOOD POINT IF THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS THIS BILL AND THIS BILL
PASSES. THERE IS A TRANSITION
PERIOD LIKE THE AUTHOR SAID THE
AUTHOR SAYS THERE'S A
TRANSITION CREATED THERE IS AND
IT'S IDENTIFIED ON. PAGE FIVE
AS WELL SECTION. TWO EIGHT AND
THEN A B. AND C. SO IT SAYS ON
DATE. FIRST YOU KNOW. A FEW
MONTHS FROM NOW ON JANUARY
FIRST OUT OF THOSE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED WE'LL HAVE T GO BACK
TO THE TRAINING COURSE WHAT
SIXTY THREE HUNDRED. WHICH ONES.
AGAIN I JUST I'M ASKING FOR A
GUARANTEE I'D LIKE TO THINK MY
CALLING FROM STOCKTON WHO. YOU
HAVE GOT NO IDEA THE OIL
INDUSTRY'S CAME AFTER YOU LIKE
NO TOMORROW AND- YOU STILL
LOOK. AT NOT A PUNITIVE
SITUATION BUT THAT. TRUE
INDIVIDUALS CALIFORNIANS BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES PEOPLE OF
COLOR INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
VETERANS AND SECOND CANCERS.
THIS INDUSTRY PROVIDES AN
EXCELLENT PAINT JOB YOU TALKED
ABOUT SKILLED AND TRAINED THE
NUMBERS SHOW THEMSELVES ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS- WEBSITE. THIS IS ONE
OF THE SAFEST INDUSTRIES OUT
THERE IS NOT THE SAFEST. AND
LIKE I SAID I THINK THE OIL
INDUSTRY IS SEVEN. IS UNDER
ATTACK IT'S EVIDENT BUT I THINK
IT'S THE ONE OF THE GREATEST
INDUSTRIES IN THE WORLD BECAUSE
IT DOES OFFER INDIVIDUALS JOBS
AND IT DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY TYPE
OF SPECIAL TRAINING OR- OR I
SEE SPECIAL TRAINING IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE ANY COLLEGE DEGREE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK THERE. THE
SPECIAL TRAINING THEY GET IS A
CRAFT TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WAS
DESIGNED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
BY THE INDUSTRY- I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO. TO HER OWN
ADMISSION IS DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO SHUT DOWN A
PARTICULAR LEASING LOS ANGELES.
REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE JOBS IN THIS
INDUSTRY. AND- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA. RIGHT AGAIN
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WHO
WAS ON THE CALL THIS MORNING.
AT THE ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE
IT'S AGAIN IT'S NOT ABOUT THESE
PEOPLE BEING FIRED IT'S ABOUT
THEM HAVING TO HAVE THE
CERTIFICATION IN THE PROCESS.
OF THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
TO GO THROUGH AN APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM. THESE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEN OPERATING SAFELY
FOR ALL THESE YEARS- WITH THE
LOWEST SAFETY INCIDENT READING
THAT'S AVAILABLE ON THE STATE
WEBSITE. AND DON'T HAVE THAT
TRAINING THEY MAKE EXCELLENT
WAGES MANY OF THEM HAVE COMPANY
VEHICLES MANY OF THEM HAVE A-
FOUR OH ONE K. PLAN A
RETIREMENT PROGRAM. SOME PEOPLE
EVEN HAVE BRIAN'S IN SOMEBODY'S
CONTRACTOR COMPANY OR COMPANY
OR EMPLOYEE OWNED- IT'S A GREAT
INDUSTRY. AGAIN THIS IS NOT AN
ANTI UNION BILL THIS IS A PRO
WORKER BILL. AND I EVEN REACHED
OUT IN KERN COUNTY 1100% ONE
HUNTER I BLEED OIL YOU KNOW- I
THINK IT'S A GREAT INDUSTRY
AVERAGE OUT TO ROBIN HUNTER. TO
SEE IF HE WOULD TALK TO ME
ABOUT THIS BILL AND SEE IF WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD ON SOME WAY.
TO SAVE THEIR JOBS AND MAKE
SURE NO ONE IS DISPLACED. IS
NOT AN ANTI UNION ILL THIS IS
A PRO WORKER BILL AND AGAIN AND
THANK YOU FOR LET ME DO A
LITTLE CROSS TO BEAR TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE.
THAT WERE ADDRESSED AND I THINK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AND ESPECIALLY- ALL OF THAT THE
CALL IS ON THE OTHER SIDE
ISLAND SENATOR BATES. I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THAT ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT WERE- ABOUT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
CENTER GROUP CENTER FOR TULLOW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I WILL KEEP IT SHORT
AND SIMPLE JUST BECAUSE I HAVE
SAID THIS BEFORE AND I'M GONNA
SAY IT AGAIN. KERN COUNTY NEEDS
TO BE LEADING THE CONVERSATION
ON THE TRANSITION AND WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. KERN COUNTY AND
THE PEOPLE FROM COUNTY ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO SKILLED AND TRAINED.
AND THEY'RE ADJUSTING TO THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE TO DO THAT
THERE WILL BE A TRANSITION. SO
OBVIOUSLY FROM THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. THIS BILL
NEEDS WORK AND- UNTIL IT IS
WORKED ON I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS. THAT
WE'VE HAD TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HER TADO MEMBERS
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR STERN PLEASE
CLOSE. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. TRYING TO SEEK SOME
CLARIFICATION FROM OUR A
PARLIAMENTARIAN WHETHER WE CAN
TABLE THIS DISCUSSION SO I CAN
ACTUALLY TRY TO WORK- THE SOME
OF THIS OUT WITH THE MEMBERS-
BUT IT SEEMS THAT WE HAVE TO
BRING THE BILL UP FOR A VOTE
NOW- HI- FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'LL IT'LL
CHANGE. FOLKS MINDS. IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S A- VARIETY OF
PROPOSALS BEING PUT OUT THERE
AND DO NOT LIKE TO AMEND THE
BILL ON THE FLY- THE ONE
CONCRETE THING I GUESS I WOULD
OFFERS I'M WILLING- TO LOOK AT.
HI A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
DATE FOR THAT FIRST DATE WE
TALKED ABOUT. SO IF IT WOULD
HELP. MEMBERS- TO PUT. AT THE
TOP OF PAGE FIVE THAT THAT
TRANSITION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IF IT HELPS TO MOVE IT FROM- AS
OF JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT LEAST THIRTY PERCENT. TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I HAVE AT
LEAST 30% TO THE START THE
STAIR STEP THEN. I'M GOING TO
COMMIT TO THAT NOW AND IT WILL
JUST SAY IS- THE PUT THE BILL
UP AND IT DOESN'T HAVE THE
VOTES INITIALLY WE CAN KEEP
TALKING THE DAY GOES ON IT GETS
OUT THOUGH- I WILL COMMIT TO
YOU ALL- TO CLARIFY IF
NECESSARY IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT.
NO ONE WILL BE FIRED BY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
THAT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT-
IF THERE NEEDS TO BE RESTATED
IN A LAW. ON I THINK IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR IN THE BILL BUT I
I'M I'M WILLING TO. TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE- BUT WITHOUT
UNDERCUTTING THE OVERALL. THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL THAT
THROUGH THIS TRANSITION WE DO
WANT FOLKS TO GET PREVAILING
WAGER TO BEAT SKILLS OR ANY
PERSON OR TO BE A- DIFFERENCE.
I KNOW WE BELIEVE IN THIS
DEBATE AND I MEAN I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER WORK TO
GET TO TODAY- BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY- YOU KNOW TO. TO THE CENTER
OF SANTA BARBARA'S POINT ABOUT
THE BIGGER CONVERSATION. I SO
APPRECIATE THE DILIGENCE OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS AND THE
DEATH AND I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
BEEN- PRETTY DEAF EARS OR
WOULDN'T TAKE ANY OF THE
CONCERNS OR- OR PLAYING A GAME.
I JUST WISH WE WOULD TAKE
CLIMATE CHANGE SERIOUSLY IN
THIS CHAMBER. I WISH E WOULD
HAVE THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE INADEQUACY OF STATE
LAW RIGHT NOW TO MAKE A
TRANSITION THIS DECADE. NONE OF
THOSE BILLS ARE MOVING. DAN CAN
YOU STICK TO THE BILL IN HAND
PLEASE. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WAS REFERRING TO
MY COLLEGE OF SANTA BARBARA'S
COMMENTS ABOUT. THE BIGGER
CONVERSATION OCCURRING HERE SO
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
AND I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW
THIS DEBATE- AN ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN DOES NEED
TO BE PUT IN PLACE AND THEN
MAYBE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE ASKING
FOR. IN THAT TRANSITION.
WHATEVER THAT FRAMEWORK OUGHT
TO BE OF A JOBS GUARANTEE THAT
MAY BE BIGGER THAN THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL. SO FOR THAT PIECE OF
A JOBS GUARANTEE. THAT YOU WILL
NEVER GET PROFESSIONAL NOT
CHANGING YOU WILL FOREVER BE IN
THAT LINE OF WORK. I THINK IT'S
BIGGER THAN THIS BILL CAN TAKE
ON. AND I THINK THAT HAS TO BE
NEGOTIATED IN THE CONTEXT OF A
BROADER. CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN
THAT WE JUST PASSED IMPORTANT
PIECE OF YESTERDAY. FROM A
CENTER CENTER FROM LOS ANGELES
BUT I'M WILLING NOW TO OFFER.
ONE YEAR DELAYED- TIME FRAME
AND AS NECESSARY WE CAN
CONTINUE. THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT. HOW TO FIND SOME- SORT
OF CLARIFICATION AROUND THE
FIFTH THE THIS IS THIS ON A
FALSE PREMISE THAT PEOPLE BE
FIRED BY THE BILL I THINK YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD SAY. SHE'S NOT
SAYING THAT. NO ONE WILL BE
FIRED BY THIS BILL IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THAT. SO THE EXPERT. ON
THIS LEGISLATION HERE- IN OUR
HOUSE HE'S SAYING IT DOESN'T DO
THAT. JUST WANTS TO KNOW WHO IS
70% OF PEOPLE ARE KEY GET TO DO
THEIR JOB. SO ILL OFFER THAT
IN MY CLOTHES- AND BEG FOR A-
PICTURE THIS DILIGENCE- AS A
BODY OUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
BIG PICTURE TO. RESPECTFULLY
ASKING I THOUGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA OR I. ATKINS I BASE
NO BECKER. GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD.
CABRERA CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD.
THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO I. FOR TANTO. JONES
NO CAN WALKER. I LAYERED HI
LABOUR HI THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH NO HAN.
PORTS AND TINA I ROCKED. RUBIO
SKINNER I STERN. I AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE THREE FIVE WINNER.
WELL. NOW PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN BACKER. BRADFORD
CABRERO. DALLY DODD. BAGMAN
GLAZER. BEN SOLACE. HER TADO.
THE MON. MEN. FIVE NIELSEN. PAN
RALPH. RUBIO WINNER. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR
CORTESE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THE BILL. SENATE BILL TWO
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE
AN ACT RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SIR ROSE
TODAY TO PRESENT SP TWO
THIRTEEN WHICH WILL CREATE A
WORKERS COMPENSATION REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES. I DIRECT PATIENT
CARE IN ACUTE HOSPITAL SETTINGS
YOUR FACE HIGH RISK OF ILLNESS
AND INJURIES SUCH AS INFECTIOUS
DISEASE MUSCULOSKELETAL INJURY-
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
IN COLD NINETEEN- LET ME-
INTERJECTED PAUSE AND SAY THAT-
I HAVE- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW. HI
TWENTY YEARS PRIOR TO COMING
HERE AND GOVERNMENT
TWELVE ON THE SENECA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHICH RUNS
UP ONE OF THE LARGEST PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS IN THE
UNITED STATES MULTIPLE
HOSPITALS. MULTIPLE CLINICS
BLOCKS OF HOSPITAL WORKERS- I
ALSO IN A COUNTY THAT HAS A
VERY ROBUST PRIVATE SECTOR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM- I BEEN AWARE
BUT THERE COULD BE ISSUES OF
FAIRNESS ISSUES FOR A LONG TIME
INTERACTED ON THEM. IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN SOMETHING LONG
AGO THAT I COMMITTED TO- WAS
RIGHT WHEN I GOT HERE. TO DO
WHAT I NEEDED TO DO TO BEGIN TO
BRING EQUITY. TO THESE WORKERS
IN A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FIELD.
BUT SO I WANT TO TELL YOU- WHAT
KIND OF ACTIVITY AND WHY.
EXISTING LAW ONLY PROVIDES
CERTAIN TYPES OF FRONTLINE
PROFESSIONALS. ELIGIBILITY FOR
WORKER'S COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE A
FORTY THESE PROTECTIONS OR
PRESUMPTIONS RECRUIT EMTS
PARAMEDICS FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS ALL OF WHICH BY
THE WAY ARE CURRENTLY MALE
DOMINATED FIELDS LET ME GIVE
YOU THOSE STATISTICS. ACCORDING
TO UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR SEVEN OUT OF EIGHT POLICE
OFFICERS ARE MEN. NINETEEN OUT
OF TWENTY FIREFIGHTERS ARE MEN.
THREE OUT OF FOUR EMTS ARE MEN.
MEANWHILE FRONTLINE WORKERS
WORK IN HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
SUCH AS NURSES THOSE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE PANDEMIC
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF.
THEY'RE NOT ENTITLED TO THE
SAME WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS THIS IS DESPITE
THE FACT. THAT NURSES PROTECT
THE SAME POPULATION IN OUR
HOSPITALS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS PROTECT IN THE FIELD.
NINE OUT OF TEN REGISTERED
NURSES ARE WOMEN. THE CORE OF
THIS BILL IS SIMPLE. S. P. TWO
THIRTEEN RECOGNIZES AND
ADDRESSES A GLARING INEQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. IT
CORRECTS A HISTORICAL WRONG
MATE DURING A VERY DIFFERENT
TIME LONG AGO. EQUITY IS ONLY
POSSIBLE WHEN ALL FRONTLINE
PROFESSIONALS WHO FACE THE SAME
RISK OF ILLNESS AND INJURY TO
THE NATURE OF THEIR WORK ARE
GIVEN THE SAME GUARANTEED
BENEFITS. HOW MANY MORE YEARS
MUST PASS AND HOW MANY MORE
EXCUSES MUST WE MAKE BEFORE WE
DO WHAT'S RIGHT. DESPITE MY
RELUCTANCE AGREED TO SCALE BACK
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL TO
ADDRESS MY COLLEAGUES CONCERNED
SO LET ME SAY RELUCTANT AS I
MAY BE I APPRECIATE THE
COOPERATION I PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THOSE. WHO COME
FORWARD WITH SPECIFICS- THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY DEAL WITH. WITHOUT
DOING SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN A SIRI THE INTENT OF THE
BILL SO I AGREED TO REMOVE
CANCER. CPO COPD AND ASTHMA
FROM THE BILL IN- THOSE WILL BE
OFFERING THEMIT'S ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE BUT THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT SPECIFIC CLAIMS. AND
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN WILLING TO
WORK ON THE SCOPE. IN FACT 92%
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS-
PROVED WITH THIS DEMOGRAPHIC.
WITH THE SPILL ABOUT AGAIN IS
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD. S.
P. TWO THIRTEEN IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
RESOLVING THE ECONOMIC AND
GENDER INEQUITY THAT PERVADES
OUR SOCIETY TO STAY. ALL THREE
THIS BILL HAS BEEN A FURTHER I
OPENING EXPERIENCE AFTER MY
TWELVE YEARS AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WERE WITNESSED FIRST
HAND FIRST HAND. IN THIS
DOCUMENT RESPONDED TO MOTOR
BOATS IN LETTERS AND FACE TO
FACE MEETINGS. FIRSTHAND
HOSPITALS UNDERCUTTING THE WORK
FORCE PRETTYPROFITS OVER
PEOPLE AND THE WORKERS. SO
AGAIN I MADE A PROMISE TO
MYSELF. TO DO THIS KIND OF WORK.
UPON ARRIVING HERE IN THIS
WON'T BE THE LAST TIME THAT YOU
HEAR ME COMING FROM A PLACE OF
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS. THE GAP IN
ACCESS TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
EXPERIENCE POORER NURSES. IS A
WRONG MUST BE CORRECTED. FOR ME
TO SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT. ANY EXCUSE TO REAL LIFE
EXAMPLES. AGAIN AS I JUST
STATED BASED ON LABOR
STATISTICS. FIREFIGHTERS AND
EMTS ARE 90% MALE. NURSES ARE
90% WOMEN. WHAT EMT ARRIVES AT
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. GET HANDS
OFF A PATIENT ON A GURNEY. AND
HE HURTS HIS OWN. HE HAS A
WORKERS COMP PRESUMPTION. RIGHT
NOW. IN THAT MOMENT. WHEN HE
HANDS THE PATIENT ON THE GURNEY
OVER TO THE WOMAN NURSE AND SHE
HURT HER ARM. IN THE SAME WAY
SHE HAS NO WORKERS COMP
PRESUMPTION. SAME CONTINUUM OF
CARE. IT SAME ACUITY OF CARE
SAME FRONTLINE STATUS. IN THAT
SPLIT SECOND DURING THE HEAD
OFF. THE CURRENT PRESUMPTION
DISAPPEARS. WHAT'S HAPPENING
THERE. I ASK AGAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE. YOUR UNION
ISSUES VERSUS NON ISSUES NON
UNION ISSUES. IT'S ABOUT EQUITY.
IN OUR HEAD. COLLEAGUES GOOD
COLLEAGUES CLOSE COLLEAGUE SAID
TO ME YES BUT IT WOULD SET A
PRECEDENT. COLLEAGUES I DIDN'T
HERE.THIS FOR THE STATUS QUO
WHEN IT COMES TO-AND I DON'T
THINK MOST OF YOU CAME HERE FOR
THE EITHER I THINK WE'RE HERE
TO SET PRECEDENT ESPECIALLY IN
AN AREA LIKE THIS. AND THE
PRESIDENT IN THIS CASE IS WHAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT OVER FIFTY
YEARS IN THIS COUNTRY. THAT THE
WORK WOMEN DO. IS EQUAL. TO THE
WORK THAT MEN DO AND SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED THE SAME WAY.
WORKERS COMPENSATION SHOULD
FOLLOW THAT RULE EQUITY FOR ALL
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN EQUITY FOR
WOMEN. I EVEN HAD A CLOSE
COLLEAGUE JUST LOOK AT ME AND
SAY WHY. IN THE PERIPHERIES
BOBBY KENNEDY. SOME PEOPLE LOOK
AT THINGS AS THEY ARE AND SAY
WHY I THINK WE'RE HERE. TO LOOK
AT THINGS THAT NEVER WERE AND
SAY WHY NOT AND I THINK THIS
KIND OF EQUITY IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
BASICS NO BACKER. HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD. BY ADAM HI COURTESY.
I DALLY NO DOG. THE RUSSELL BY
ADMIN I GLAZER NO GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO.
HI HER TADO. JONES NO CAMERA
OVER. LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE
MON. MAGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MAN. NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. OCHO A
VOGUE NO PAN. FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER FIVE STERN.
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
WINNER I WILL KNOW. SENATOR
MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE SENATOR ALAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
ALAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR ALAN. EXCUSE
ME- THIS BILL IMPROVES ELECTION
TRANSPARENCY BY UPDATING AND
CLARIFYING DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS ON POLITICAL
ADVERTISING AND THE PETITION
PROCESS ARE WE SEEING AND SOME
SOME NEW TACTICS IN THIS SPACE
OF COURSE I WAS ALWAYS MOVES
TO- TO TRY TO AVOID
TRANSPARENCY BY CIRCUMVENTING
CURRENT DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
SO FORMATTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
POLITICAL TV ADS ALLOW ADD
FUNDERS TO MAKE TEXT I'M CLEAR
TO VIEWERS AND ONLINE GRAPHIC
ADS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO DISPLAY
ANY TOP CONTRIBUTORS. SOME
PETITION SIGNATURE GATHERS HAVE
NOT BEEN SHOWING VOTERS A
LITTLE LIST OF TOP FUNDERS OF
THE PETITION CAMPAIGN AS
REQUIRED BY LAW. THE END. ZACKS
HAVE UTILIZED A LOOPHOLE TO
HIDE THEIR TOP FUNDERS AND
LOCAL AND LEGISLATIVE RACES
WITH MANY CONTRIBUTORS WITH
MANY CONTRIBUTIONS JUST UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
CONTRIBUTED 490-009-0090 NINE I
JUST TO AVOID DISCLOSURE UNDER
THE CURRENT DISCLOSE ACT
THRESHOLD SO IT'S BILL UPDATES
FORMATTING REQUIREMENTS ON TV
AND ONLINE ADVERTISEMENTS IT
LOWERS THE THRESHOLD TO BE
CONSIDERED A TOP CONTRIBUTOR TO
LOCAL LEGISLATIVE AND BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION RACES- THE BUILD
BRINGS MUCH NEEDED CLARITY TO
OUR POLITICAL PROCESS AND- AND
PROVIDES VOTERS WITH VITAL
INFORMATION TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS I HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH SOME OF OUR-
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO. SEE
IF WE CAN. MAKE SOME SOME SOME
SOME CHANGES TO THE BILL TO
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
PALATABLE TO SOME OF THE IT'S A
DRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY HAVE I THINK WE'RE AT
WE'RE- WELL ON OUR WAY. IN A
GOOD CONVERSATION- ON THAT BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THE LAWS WE
PASSED. SO FAR WILL WILL
ACTUALLY BE MEETING IN THAT
THAT WILL PROVIDE. THE TYPE OF
DISCO. THAT- THAT THE VOTE AND-
AS THEY MAKE DECISION SO-
WITHOUT I RESPECT I THRIVE.
THANK YOU SO ALAN MEMBERS. OR
TO BE. CENTER BORJAS. I JUST
WANTED TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR-
JUST FOR THIS BILL BUT THE WORK
THAT HE'S DONE- IN PROMOTING
TRANSPARENCY- IN THE ELECTIONS
PROCESS I KNOW THAT. A LOT OF
FOLKS- HAVE- DIFFERENT VIEWS
AND PASSIONATELY THE- ARE
CRITICAL OR ADVOCATE FOR HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSE ABILITY- TO PROMOTE-
TRUST IN OUR ELECTION PROCESS.
AND I'VE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE-
ALL THE WHILE OF FOR FOOD FOR
THOSE EFFORTS AND I KNOW THEY
THEY WILL CONTINUE- IT IS ONE
OF COMMAND OF THE ALTAR FOR THE
WORKERS OF STONE AND THE SPACE.
HOPEFULLY THERE WILL BE SOME
CHANGES FIVE MOVED TO THE
SECOND HOUSE AND- IMPROVE UPON
THE PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW. THE YOU SENATOR BORDER
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONCENTRAL WHICH I'D CLOSE
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO I'M I
REALLY DO WANT THIS TO BE A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT I'M
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOUR- CAUCUS ON ON SOME OF
THE CHANGES THAT WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING- SO THAT THIS
BECOMES A- TRULY BIPARTISAN
EFFORT AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS A
GREAT DEAL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK MY COLLEAGUES FROM A VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS.
BASED BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING HI DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI AIKMAN. GLAZER. FIVE
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE WAY SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER. FIVE
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI WE MOAN.
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. MAN
FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOTH. PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN. AMBERG HI MY CASKEY I
WINNER. HI WELK. WE'RE ON CALL
RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE THE BILL ON CALL AND WE'LL
TAKE IT UP WHEN WE TAKE THE
BILLS OFF CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK MEMBERS ARE MOVING
OUT OF FIVE AND TWENTY SEVEN
SENATOR GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
BY PROVIDING THE FUNDS
NECESSARY THEREFORE THROUGH AN
ELECTION. FOR THE ISSUANCE AND
SALE OF BONDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE HANDLING
AND DISPOSITION OF THESE FUNDS.
SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE A
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO VALID.
FOR FACILITIES FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED
FOR ALL OF US THE NEED FOR SAFE
SCHOOLS AND CAMPUS FACILITIES.
THAT PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
CHILDREN AND STAFF. CURRENTLY
MANY SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT BUILDING SPACE TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
RE OPENING GUIDELINES ON
SMALLER CLASS SIZES. NOW THIS
BILL IS AN EXTENSION OF
COMPROMISES THAT OCCURRED FOR
THE MEASURE. THAT YOU ADVANCE
HERE IN THE SENATE LAST YEAR. I
KNOW THERE ARE MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSION TO
HAVE WITH LEADERSHIP AND THE
GOVERNOR. TO FASHION THIS IN A
WAY THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED. L.
AS A FIRST STEP IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT IT ALLOWS THE
SENATE. TO STAND UP FOR
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS WE WANT
TO SEE IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND
UNIVERSITIES AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. BAIT BACKER. HI FIVE FOUR
JUST. BRADFORD I COME EITHER
FIVE OR TEN THREE. HI DALLY NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN.
HI PLEASE- FIVE DOLLARS I GROW.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. OCHO A VOGUE
NO HAND FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW
HI ROB FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
HI STERN. HI I'M BERG HI FOR
CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WELL NOW.
SOON REMOVED THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR GLAZER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR FORTY SIX BY
SEATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE CENTER
CLOSER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP FOUR FOUR
SIX WOULD CLEAR HURDLES THAT
TOO OFTEN KEEP THE WRONGLY
CONVICTED FROM BEING
COMPENSATED FOR TIME THEY SPENT
I JUSTLY IMPRISONED. THIS BILL
WOULD PUT THE BURDEN ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IN
COMPENSATION CLAIMS RATHER THAN
THE REQUIRED THE PERSON WHO'S
BEEN WRONGLY CONVICTED TO
PROVE. THEY ARE INNOCENT. WHY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO OBJECT
TO ONLY THOSE CLAIMS IN WHICH
THEY BELIEVE THE PERSON SHOULD
NOT BE COMPENSATED. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MUST THEN
PROVE BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE. THAT THE CLAIMANT IS
NOT ENTITLED. TO COMPENSATION.
IF THE AG DOES NOT TAKE UP THE
CASE THE COMPENSATION CLAIMS
WOULD GO FORWARD. THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD WE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
APPROVE THIS- THE CLAIM AMOUNT
AND SEND IT TO THE LEGISLATURE
FINAL APPROVAL- MANY HAVE SPENT
YEARS EVEN DECADES BEHIND BARS
BEFORE THERE AND CONVICTIONS
HAVE BEEN OVERTURNED SINCE THAT
THIS IS AN INTERESTING FACT
EXTRAORDINARY FACTS SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. THERE
HAVE BEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE CALIFORNIA INMATES WHO
HAVE OBTAINED COURT REVERSAL OF
THEIR CONVICTIONS AND HAVE BEEN
RELEASED FROM PRISON AFTER
SPENDING YEARS FIGHTING TO
PROVE THEIR WRONGFUL
CONVICTION. AND DECADES
UNJUSTLY BEHIND BARS. HOWEVER
ONCE THESE WRONGLY CONVICTED
PERSONS TO OBTAIN COURT
REVERSALS THEY MUST RE LITIGATE
THEIR CASE TO ENSURE THEY'RE
FAIRLY FAIRLY COMPENSATED. THIS
IS PROVEN TO BE AN UNFAIR AND
UNJUST BURDEN ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY DETERMINED TO BE
WRONGLY CONVICTED. I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL
TODAY WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A- BIG CENTER
GLAZER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA%
HI ATKINS. BASE FIVE BECKER I
FORGES. BRADFORD BYE BYE ADAM.
CORTESE HI DALLY I DON. I
TORONTO. HI ADNAN I BELIEVE- HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH FIVE
HURTS BERG FIVE WEST SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LISA HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S HI MAN I.
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW UP
BOTH I PAN FIVE PORTS IN TINO
FIVE ROCK. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
I STERN I AM BERG HI HI WHAT
COUNTS THREE FIVE WINNER. I
WILL I DIDN'T REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR ROTH MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
SEVERAL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES CONSIDER
BELLATOR THREE IS THE SUNSET
BILL FOR THE BOARD OF BARBERING
AND COSMETOLOGY SUNSET BILL
THAT IS CURRENTLY BECAUSE A LOT
OF CONSTERNATION. IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUTSIDE. JUST
TO LET YOU KNOW WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
TO THE OPERATION OF THE BOARD
AND PROVISIONS IN THE ACT
STEMMING FROM OUR JOINT SUNSET
REVIEW OPERATION. AND THOSE
CHANGES INCLUDE MODIFYING THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD TO
INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE VARIOUS OCCUPATIONS
REGULATED BY THE BOARD.
UPDATING THE TRAINING PRACTICE
REQUIREMENTS FOR BARBERS AND
COSMETOLOGISTS. REMOVES THE-REQUIREMENT FOR COMPLETION OF A
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION PRIOR TO
LICENSURE BUT SUBSTANTIALLY
ENHANCES THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE WRITTEN EXAMINATION
INCLUDING REQUIREMENTS WITH
REGARD TO HEALTH SAFETY
SANITATION AND DISINFECTION
PROCEDURES PRACTICES AND LAWS.
BENNETT LESLIE PLEASED IN TERMS
OF THIS LIST UPDATES THE NUMBER
OF MANDATORY HOURS OF TRAINING
THE APPLICANT MUST COMPLETE IN
ORDER TO BECOME LICENSED BY THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. INCLUDING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF HOURS
OF SAFETY AND HEALTH CURRICULUM
AN APPLICANT MUST COMPLETE FROM
SIXTY FIVE HOURS OUTLINED IN
THE EGULATIONS TWO ONE HALF
HUNDRED HOURS SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL IN ORDER TO PROTECT.
LICENSEES AND CONSUMERS IN
PURPLE PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THROUGH KNOWLEDGE IN TOPICS
SUCH AS HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES
CHEMICALS AND HEALTH. HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS AGENCIES
BACTERIOLOGICAL. AND PREVENTING
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES INFECTION
AND SANITATION FOR EXAMPLE.
TERMS OF THE GNU HOURS THE BILL
REQUIRES ONE HUNDRED HOURS OF
TRAINING AND DISINFECTION AND
SANITATION. WHICH IS A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE FROM THE
TWENTY HOURS REQUIRED PRESENTLY
ON THOSE PARTICULAR SUBJECTS.
NOW THIS TRAINING OUR
REQUIREMENT IS PROBABLY THE
MOST CONTENTIOUS. IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS FOR COSMETOLOGISTS AND
FIFTEEN HUNDRED HOURS OF
TRAINING FOR BARBERS. NOW WE
ALL KNOW LICENSING AND TRAINING
CAN BE A BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED. AT THE SAME TIME
I THINK ALL OF US CLEARLY
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TRAINING.
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NOT ONLY OF THE INDIVIDUALS
PROVIDING THE CARE IN THIS CASE
BARBERS COSMETOLOGISTS AND
ALIKE. BUT CONSUMERS. NOW IN
THIS LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY.
BEFORE MY TIME AND DURING MY
TIME. WE HAVE DISCUSSED THIS
ISSUE FOR YEARS. WE'VE ASKED
THE BOARD AND WE HAVE ASKED THE
INDUSTRY FOR HELP. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE ANYWAY THE BOARD IS
NEVER EVALUATED THE ACTUAL
RISKS TO THE CONSUMERS M.
LICENSEES. EVALUATED WHERE
SPECIFIC HARM ARISES IN
JUSTIFYING THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOUR TRAINING REQUIREMENT FOR
COSMETOLOGISTS AND THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED REQUIRED OUR
REQUIREMENT FOR BARBERS YES.
THE STANDARD CONTINUES TO EXIST
TODAY DESPITE SEVERAL REQUESTS
BY MY PREDECESSORS AND BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. FOR AN
EVALUATION AND HELP IN
EVALUATING THESE STANDARDS SO.
IN THIS BILL WE SET THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ONE
THOUSAND HOURS FOR BARBERS AND
COSMETOLOGISTS IN AS I
INDICATED PREVIOUSLY
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED
REQUIREMENTS IN THE AREAS OF
HEALTH SAFETY DISINFECTION AND
SANITATION WHEN WE SET THIS ONE
THOUSAND R. REQUIREMENTS BASED
ON INPUT FROM THE BOARD NOW.
AND OUR EXAMINATION OF CHANGES
MADE IN SEVERAL OTHER STATES IN
THIS NATION FOR THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN REDUCED.
AMAT IN TEXAS DOWN TO ONE
THOUSAND HOURS RHODE ISLAND
DOWN TO SIX HUNDRED HOURS NEW
YORK AND OTHERS CONTINUING.
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE
HEARING THAT WE CONDUCTED AND I
JUST HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
CHAIRING. WE HAD VERY LITTLE
INPUT FROM INDUSTRY DURING THE
PUBLIC HEARING AND I SAY
UNFORTUNATELY. OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO GET THIS THING RIGHT WE
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS PARTICULARLY
IN THIS AREA. ENCOURAGING
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR ALL. WELL
WE ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS ARE
FULLY TOTALLY. PROTECTED WE
WILL CONTINUE TO GET THIS THING
RIGHT AS YOU KNOW WITH THIS
SUNSET BILL IS WITH ALL OF THE
OTHERS WE HAVE CONSIDERED AND
WILL CONSIDER- IN THIS HOUSE
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS IT'S
A JOINT PROCESS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY THE BILL WILL CLEARLY
CONTINUE TO TAKE SHAPE
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT NUMBER OF
MONTHS IN THE FEEDBACK FROM OUR
VALUABLE INDUSTRY PARTNERS. WHO
HAVE SPENT YEARS HONING THEIR
SKILLS WILL BE KEY AND THAT
INCLUDES THE SCHOOLS WILL BE
KEY TO DETERMINING THE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION FOR THE BOARD
OF BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY IN
THE FUTURE AND THE STATE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
IMPOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND LISTENING TO ME
AND HAT THE PROPRIOCEPTIVE
RICK RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SO I'M I'M
STANDING TODAY TOO AND I'M
GOING TO BE- LAYING OFF AS P.
EIGHT OH THREE- THIS AFTERNOON.
WITH MY APOLOGIES. TO MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM RIVERSIDE WHO I
THINK IS AN EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
CHAIR THERE'S BEEN SOME- LATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AGAIN
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL HAS SAID
THAT HE WILL WORK WITH HIM ON
THE OTHER SIDE IS MENTIONING IT
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT-
WHEN YOU THINK OF ICONIC
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA YOU
THINK OF YOU KNOW WALT DISNEY
COMPANY. H. P. M. T. N. AND
WHEN YOU THINK OF. PRODUCTS YOU
THINK A PAUL MITCHELL SYSTEMS.
WHICH WAS A CALIFORNIA COMPANY
WHEN PAUL MITCHELL AND JOHN
PAUL DEJORIA WHO STARTED THE
COMPANY JOHN PAUL WAS LIVING IN
HIS CAR THEY HAD TO BORROW
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS TO START
THE COMPANY. TODAY THEIR
PRODUCTS ARE SOLD IN EIGHTY
EIGHT COUNTRIES AROUND THE
GLOBE. IN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE THEY STARTED-
COSMETOLOGY SCHOOLS CURRENTLY
THEY HAVE A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY THEY
JUST RECENTLY OPENED ONE IN
EUROPE IN CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
SCHOOLS IN PLEASANT HILL
MODESTO FRESNO TWO IN
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO
TRUCKEE SAN JOSE. PASADENA TO
MACULA SANDIEGO COSTA MESA IN
SHERMAN OAKS. DAN WHAT'S WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS SO ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL
IS AND AGAIN IT'S ALL AS FAR AS
WE KNOW IT'S ARBITRARY IS AT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS NOW THIS
FEEL WANT TO TAKE IT DOWN TWO.
THOUSAND ONLY THREE STATES THAT
ARE A THOUSAND ONE OF THOSE
TAXES. AND WE DON'T HAVE A
HISTORY OF FALLING TEXAS WE
WANT TEXAS TO FOLLOW US. IT WAS
A CHALLENGE WITH THAT IF YOU DO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE
LEADING WE HAD A- COLLEAGUE FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MET THAT
EARLIER THIS WEEK. AND YOU GO
TO ANOTHER STATE IF WE WERE A
THOUSAND YOU WENT TO ANOTHER
STATE. YOU COULD NOT START
WORKING IMMEDIATELY YOU WOULD
HAVE TO GO AND MAKE UP MAKE UP
THOSE HOURS. AND I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT WORKS. ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THERE SO MANY HOURS
AT LEAST ON THE ON THE PAUL
MITCHELL SCHOOLS. BECAUSE NOT
ONLY HEALTH AND SAFETY WHICH IS
QARAMADA SLEEP AFTER WHAT WE'VE
JUST BEEN THROUGH. AND
OBVIOUSLY CUTTING HERE
CONFIDENTLY. BUT ALSO BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW THE INTERESTING THING
WHICH I DIDN'T LEARN UNTIL THIS
WEEK. IS THAT ONLY GOT EIGHT
POINT FIVE PERCENT. OF HAIR
STYLIST. WORKING THOSE BIG BOX.
WHERE THEIR THEIR STANDPOINT
YOU'RE MENTALLY RELATIONSHIP. A
NINETY ONE POINT 5% ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ENTREPRENEURS. THEY GO
OUT IN THE V. RENT A BOOTH AND
THEY CONDUCT THEIR OWN BUSINESS
WHY DO THEY WANT INDEPENDENCE.
MAYBE THEIR THEIR MOMS. AND
THEY- THEY WANT THAT THEY WANT
THE FLEXIBILITY SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE'RE NOT
SENDING THESE PEOPLE TO THE
WALLS THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
THE SKILL SET NEEDED- TO BE TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND THRIVE- ONCE
THEY GO OUT INTO THE WORK
FORCE. SO I'M REALLY CONFIDENT.
WITH OUR THROUGH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO FIND THE SWEET SWEET
SPOT BETWEEN EFFICIENCY OF THE
PROGRAM. AND GETTING PEOPLE
LICENSE IN A IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND ALSO THAT THEY HAVE THE
EDUCATIONAL- BACKGROUND NEEDED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT I'M
I'M LAYING OFF TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. AS WE MOVE THIS TO THE
NEXT HOUSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK FURTHER AWAY SO.
WHAT ABOUT. YOU WERE NO HE DID
NOT SPEAK. I'M SORRY I WAS TOLD
YOU WANTED TO SPEAK CENTER
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'LL TAKE CENTRE
WASTE OF TIME- AND- WHAT WHILE
I WON'T STAND UP HERE IN A-
HAVE A COMMERCIAL FOR AN
EMPLOYER IN MY DISTRICT- I DO.
HI I DO WANT TO I SUPPORTED
THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE- I
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. I
SUPPORT THE REDUCTION IN
LICENSURE HOURS- IN TRAINING-
FOR BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGISTS
TO ACQUIRE THEIR LICENSE I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK ME TO
LEAVE AND I GOT MY HAIR CUT
LAST WEEK BUT I JUST HAD THE
BARBER TAKE A LITTLE BIT OFF-
CAN I TALK TO ME. IN THE
BUSINESS FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
AND I AND I KNEW THIS WAS
COMING UP IN. HIS NAME'S
CAPTAIN MIKE IS A CAPTAIN
MICHAEL WE DON'T WHEN YOU GOT
YOUR LICENSE. HOW MANY HOURS
DID IT TAKE TO GET YOUR LICENSE
I. IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY HE
SAID TWO HUNDRED HOURS. AND SO
OBVIOUSLY THIS HAS GROWN OVER
THE YOU KNOW THE DECADES OF
TIME- FOR FOLKS TO GET TRAINED
ON THEIR LICENSING BUT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN. SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS- TO BECOME A LICENSED
BARBER CONVENT COSMETOLOGISTS
IN CALIFORNIA THESE ARE ALL.
VERY IS THAT THEY'RE ALL
PROFESSIONALS THEY'LL TAKE
THEIR JOB VERY SERIOUS. BUT
THAT'S A LOT OF TIME AND MONEY
THAT SOMEBODY HAS TO INVEST. TO
BECOME LICENSED IN THIS
PROFESSION AND SO AS THIS BILL
PROCEEDS AND THERE'S
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO AMEND
IT AND CHANGE IT- I JUST WANT
TO ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOWARD
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF. HOURS
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WE
CAN LOWER THE BARRIERS OF ENTRY
INTO THIS PROFESSION FOR THE
MANY CALIFORNIANS THAT WANT TO
TAKE THIS PROFESSION SERIOUS
AND GET TO WORK EARNING A
LIVING SO THAT THEY CAN STAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES CENTRE ALAN AND
THEN SENATOR GLAZER. MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
THINK THIS IS GOING TO. IMPROVE
ACCESS AND I ALSO VERY MUCH
TRUST THE AUTHOR- TO STEER THIS
BILL FORWARD IN IN A IN A IN A
FAIR MANNER. I JUST WANT I DO
WANT TO I WANT TO. JUST BRING
UP ONE ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING WITH MY FRIEND
CENTER FROM FROM LOS ANGELES
CENTER. COM LOGGER. AND THIS IS
THE ISSUE YOU KNOW AS OUR AS
OUR C. BECOMES MORE MORE
DIVERSE. IT IS IMPORTANT IT IS
SO IMPORTANT. THAT THOSE FOLKS
WORKING BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY
REALLY LEARN. THE SPECIAL
SKILLS AND TRAITS. ASSOCIATED
WITH- WORKING WITH PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS.
YOUR COLLEAGUE OUR GOOD FRIEND
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR EXAMPLE
pAGO. THAT THAT DEALT WITH
ISSUES RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION FOR FOLKS- FOR
BLACK FOLKS IN TERMS OF
HAIRSTYLES IN IN ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT. I'D CENTER AND I
WERE JUST DISCUSSING WAS THE
LACK OF TRAINING AMONGST A LOT
OF FOLKS IN THE- BARBERING
WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO WORKING
WITH BLACK HAIR. HI THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I YOU KNOW IT'S
IT AND IT'S I MEAN I I'VE- THE
FUNNY THING TO SAY BUT I SPENT
A SUMMER. LIVING WORKING IN
AFRICA. AND HOW I WENT IN TO
GET MY HAIR CUT. THEY DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH MY HAIR.
AND- AND I WAS A REALLY SCARY
EXPERIENCE AND- AND I GOTTA
TELL YOU I JUST LISTED IS THAT
A VERY LITTLE BIT NAG I KIND OF
GOT OUT OF THERE AND IT REALLY
GOT ME THINKING TO MYSELF WHEN
WHAT IS IT LIKE- YOU KNOW IF
YOU. IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE LIVING
IN A COMMUNITY WHERE NOT A LOT
OF PEOPLE LOOK LIKE YOU. ARE
ALL THE AMENITIES IN THE
SERVICES ARE NOT GEARED IN
PARTICULAR TOWARDS ADDRESSING
YOUR NEEDS. OUR SOCIETY IS
BECOMING MORE MORE DIVERSE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT. THAT FOLKS IN THE
BARBERING WORLD ARE ABLE TO
WORK WITH ALL CALIFORNIANS- AND
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
AUTHOR TO COMMIT. TO TO
ENSURING THAT THAT ISSUE
CONTINUES TO BE ADDRESSED. HI
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND
WITH THAT I BELIEVE THAT
WITHOUT HIM THAT I SEEM TO HEAR
YOU WANT TO GIVE. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND SUPPORT
HIS EFFORTS. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AND I'M
CERTAINLY STANDING IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT OH THREE. HI DO WE
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUE- THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE TO- IT VANCE'S GOOD
WORK TO TRY TO FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE- HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
TRAINING. I WOULD NOTE THAT. TO
BE A POLICE OFFICER IN GENERAL
IN CALIFORNIA REQUIRES A
HUNDRED HOURS OF. TRAINING
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND
COMPARE THT TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS- TO- TO CUT YOUR HAIR.
SO SOMETHING'S OUT OF WHACK. I
WANT TO SAY TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN DIEGO- APPRECIATE HIS
REMARKS ON THE FLOOR. AND
HEARING THE STORIES- OF HIS OWN
BARBER THE ONLY. HAVING TO HAVE
TWO HUNDRED HOURS. NOW SOME
MIGHT SUGGEST THAT THAT. EFFECT
OF THOSE TWO I HOURS. MAY AND-
THAT. MAYBE COULD USE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TRAINING THAN THAT.
BUT WE'LL PUT THAT ASIDE I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
HOPE THAT THIS SENATOR WILL
CONTINUE TO GO TO WORK ON ALL
THE ISSUES AND MAKE THIS A MORE
BALANCED PROCESS FOR. BARBERS
AND COSMETOLOGISTS. WHO WANNA
GET INTO THAT PROFESSION IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZER CENTER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
JUST FOR A MOMENT THINK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO HERE IN THE SENATE IN
THIS BUILDING- THE EFFECT THAT
WE HAVE ON PEOPLE'S LIVES. THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS OF LAWS THAT
WE CHANGED ALL THE DIFFERENT
AREAS OF- THAT WE THAT WE
CHANGED THE LIVES OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO THINK ABOUT
THAT THINK ABOUT THE HOURS OF
TRAINING THAT IS SENATORS WE
ARE REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH IN
ORDER TO PUT THSE ALLIES IN
PLACE AND CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES. I COMPARE THAT TO THE
NUMBER OF HOURS THAT ARE
REQUIRED HAVE SOMEONE TO BLOW
DRY YOUR HAIR. I WOULD
RECOMMEND AN IPHONE. THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
SENATOR DOLLY. NOPE OKAY
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
THEN SENATOR RALPH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO SAY
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL REMARKS AND COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT I AM SENSITIVE TO THE
BUSINESS MODELS. THAT EXIST
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE AND THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE EMPLOYED
THERE I'M ALSO SENSITIVE TO
BOTH THE OCCUPATIONAL ISSUES
AND THE CONSUMER SAFETY ISSUES
THAT WE GRAPPLE WITH IN THIS-
SUNSET BILL AND OTHERS I HAVE
TO TELL YOU WHY. A DAY OR SO
AGO I RECEIVED A SOMEWHAT
CRITICAL EMAIL FROM THE
COSMETOLOGIST WHO CUTS MY HAIR
AND- AND SHE HAS SCISSORS AND I
WILL BE SEEING HER NEXT WEEK.
SO I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT I TAKE
THESE- COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
SERIOUSLY AND I COMMIT TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU. ON THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT YOU'VE
OFFERED- TO GET THIS THING
RIGHT SO THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA. I DO
NOT CONSIST. FATE I RECORDS I
NEED MY MIND FORTUS. NO
BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA HI
COURTESY. HI DALLEY FIFTY FIVE
GOD OKAY HI THERE AWESOME. HI
ADNAN HI GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI
WESTERN I FOR TADA HI JONES HI
KIM LONGER HI THERE HI LLEVA HI
THE MON. YOU REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW UP BOTH HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO. THE GLOWING SKINNER HI
STERN. THE RELEASE NUMBER HI BY
CAL SKI. HI WINNER. I WILL.
SENATOR MY THE BALL MEMBERS
REMOVING OF I FORTY THREE WHY
CASKEY META SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE. SENATE THIRTY EIGHT BISA
WHITE HOUSE SKI AND DID ASSAULT
WASTE. IN REBEL. MAN PRESIDENT
BECAUSE AT OTHERS OFTEN LOOK TO
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
PROGRESSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES HOWEVER THESE SIMPLY DO
NOT LOOK TO US FOR LEADERSHIP
WHEN IT COMES TO RECYCLING. AS
WE ALL KNOW OUR- BOTTLE BILL IS
BROKEN AFTER THIRTY SIX OF FIVE
YEARS AND SEVENTY FIVE THE
AMENDMENTS AND DIFFERENT BILLS
LATER IT SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LANDSCAPE THERE
ARE OVER FORTY DEPOSIT PROGRAMS
AROUND THE WORLD THAT ARE
PRACTICALLY- RUN CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF A- HANDFUL OF-
OPERATIONS THAT GO DAY TO DAY
WITH THE PUBLIC ENTITY. NONE OF
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
SUFFERING THE SAME LOSS OF
REDEMPTION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DROP IN RETENTION RATES OR DEAL
WITH THE ISSUES THAT OUR SYSTEM
HAS SP THIRTY EIGHT BEFORE YOU
ADOPT THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE BEING USED AROUND THE
WORLD. THREE SIMPLE PURPOSE
PRINCIPLES FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
AND COST SAVING SOLUTION SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY WITH ALL THE
PARTIES CONSUMER CONFIDENCE WE
PUT CONSUMERS NUMBER ONE GIVE
THEM EASY PLACES TO REDEEM AND
ENHANCE ADAPTABILITY IT
INVOLVES ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
I'LL CONTINUE TO TALK WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THEY'LL PUT
TOGETHER THE STEWARDSHIP THIS
IS THE MANUFACTURERS THE
DISTRIBUTORS. THE RECYCLERS THE
HOLDERS THE GROCERY STORES TO
RETAILERS THE CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE EVERYBODY WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FORMING OF
THIS PRIVATE ENTITY IT SETS A
HIGHER. RETENTION RATE IS 85%
AND WITH THAT I AGREE TO MY
FOLKS THANK YOU CENTER RIGHT
HEALTHY MEMBERS DISCUSSION. AND
OR DEBATE. SO SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- WE
KNOW THAT OUR. THAT OUR WASTE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE MARKETS NOW FOR MUCH OF
THE PRODUCTS THAT WE PUT IN OUR
BINS AND THE RESULTS SO WE HAD
THE EXPECTATION THERE'D BE
RECYCLED BUT WE DON'T HAVE
MARKETS THE RESULT IS THAT ARE
ABOUT THE QUANTITY OF WASTE THE
TAB AND GO TO OUR LANDFILLS OR
OTHERWISE BE FIGURED OUT HOW TO
DISPOSE IS REALLY INCREASED.
NOW THE ITEMS THAT ARE COVERED
IN THIS BILL ARE SOME OF THE
FEW TINGS LEFT THAT THERE ARE
STILL MARKETS FOR THAT ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO BE RECYCLED SO
I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CHANGE AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR RIVALS. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM CENTER
CALHOUN GEORGIA CLOSE ORIGINAL
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. I AT KINS.
EIGHT BACKER HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD. CABRERA CORTESE HI
DOLLY NO DIED HI TORONTO BY
ADMIN HI BLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER
TADO HI JONES. NO CAN WATER.
LAYERED FIVE LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. NO MAN
NO NEWMAN. HI MAN I KNOW THAT
I'VE- NEWMAN. NIELSEN BUT SHOW
A VOGUE. NO PAN. FOURTEEN TINA.
ROSS. HI RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN
HI AM BERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI
FIVE WINNER. WELK. NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT
KINS I. BASE. BRADFORD CABRERO.
LASER GROVE. WEST SO NO. KAREN
WALKER. THE MON HI. NEWMAN
NIELSEN. PAN FORTUNE TINO.
RUBIO. AMBERG I WHY CAN'T WE
KNOW HI. I'M SORRY SENATOR
BATES. THE DEBATE NO. BRADFORD
HI. ALL RIGHT TWENTY THREES I
TWENTY THREE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR SENTIMENT CHOIR
PLEASE READ M. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REPORTER A GOOD
MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT- THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW CALTRANS
TO TRANSFER THE BLUES FEATURE
CHADBOURNE GULCH BEACH
PROPERTY. OUT AND CLOSE TO
MENDOCINO COUNTY TO NONPROFIT
AGENCY ORGANIZED BY THE ROUND
VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES SURE WOULD
VALLEY BAND OF POMO INDIANS AS
WELL AS THE CAVITY VALLEY BAND
OF POMO IN PROBABLY NEEDS.
ANOTHER PRESIDENT WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT THIS PLAN WILL
SOLELY BE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
CULTURAL PROTECTION WILL BE NO
ABILITY TO DEVELOP THE PROPERTY
FOR COMMERCIAL REASONS IT WOULD
ALSO EXCLUDE ANY GAMING
POTENTIALS ON THE PROPERTY. AND
PUBLIC BEACH ACCESS MUST BE
MAINTAINED IT'S OUTLINED IN THE
BILL- AND THERE HAS TO BE
FOCUSED ON CULTURAL- IN THERE
MAY BE SOME CLOSURE OF THE
INLAND PORTION DUE TO CULTURAL
RESOURCES WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I THOUGHT I. THINK
YOU SAID REQUIRE AND JUST A
REMINDER MEMBERS WE'RE STILL
ASKING FOLKS TO FOLLOW SOCIALLY
DISTANCE AND IF YOU'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS TAKE THEM OFF THE
FLOOR PLEASE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR.
SEEING AND HEARING. NONE M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS HI
BASED. HI BECKER. HI FOR JUST
HI BRADFORD HI BYRON HI CORTESE.
DALLY I DON. HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN. HI PLEASE SIR HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. HI HERZ
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO BY
JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED HI
LLEVA I DO MY OWN BY THE- FIVE
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF VOGUE HI PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE Y. CASKEY FIVE
WINNER. WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
OF THE MEMBERS. CORTESE I. CAN
LONGER I. NIELSEN WINNER HI.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE AND I'M FORTY FIVE
SENATOR BAKER. BUT THERE YOU
ARE THANK YOU SIR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH FOUR BY SENATOR
BECKER AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS UNDER BECKER GOOD
MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. SP FIVE BEFORE COMMON
SENSE VOTER REGISTRATION
IMPROVEMENTS FOR MILITARY
OVERSEAS A FORMAL INCARCERATED
VOTERS ESPECIALLY AS FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL
EYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
SENATOR DORADO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY BY SENATOR TO ROSS SO AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- RIGHT NOW SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES POSSESS
EITHER UNUSED REAL PROPERTY OR
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BECOME TOO
FINANCIALLY BURDENSOME TO
OPERATE AS B. THREE THIRTY
GIVES THOSE COLLEGES THE
OPPORTUNITY RE PURPOSE SUCH
UNUSED SPACE INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IT
AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO LEASES
OR AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES OR NOT PROFITS FOR
JOINT OCCUPANCY OF REAL
PROPERTY AND BUILDINGS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
OR EMPLOYEES OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL ARE PERMISSIVE. AND
PROVIDE THE COMPLETE THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT WITH
THE MEANS TO ENTER INTO THESE
AGREEMENTS ONLY IF IT REALLY
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO THEIR
NEEDS- DATE THESE INSTITUTIONS
CANNOT SERVE THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS THE STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO EVEN THE BASIC
NEEDS OF HOUSING INSTABILITY- I
PROUD I'M PROUD OF THIS BILL IS
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE HOUSING
PACKAGE HAS NO LISTED
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I ASK FOR AND I WILL THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND- OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS FIVE BASE. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
FOR TESTING. HI DALLY NO DODD
FIVE TORONTO HI EGGMAN. GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED FIVE LLEVA FIVE WE MOAN.
I REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S NO MAN
HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
BOTH. PAN. FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN. HI AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. PLEASE
FOR JUST NO. ADMIN YEAH.
NIELSEN PHOTO OF BOTH. PAN I.
WELL HI. FIVE THIRTY ONE NEWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE AND FORTY SEVEN
CENTER CORTESE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR CORTEZ
HE AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT TO. THEN
CALLING SO TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT S. P. SEVEN THIRTY NINE
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME FOR
TRANSITION AE FOSTER YOUTH ACT
RESEARCH HIGHLIGHTS THE
STRUCTURAL VULNERABILITY OF
FOSTER YOUTH WHO FACE
SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGES
COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION. BUT THERE
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
BEEN FAVORABLE EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES CONTACT THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THOSE RATES OF
SECONDARY POST SECONDARY
INDICATION AND TO NO SURPRISE
OF COURSE- NINETEEN HAS ONLY
EXACERBATED THOSE HARDSHIPS- I
JUST WANT TO CONCLUDE BY
INDICATING THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO BUY SOME COLLEAGUES BUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A SUNSET
THIS ACTUALLY A PILOT- IN- THE
MAXIMUM TERM ON THE PILOT
PRIVILEGE SOLUTION IS THREE
YEARS- SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING HEARING NONE MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
BASE. BACKER HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY OTHER HI
FOR TESTING HI SALLY. NO DODD I
DURAZO. I EGGMAN. GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAN LONGER. HI LAYERED I LLEVA
I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN. A TRAIL OF BOTH. PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES EGGMAN.
GROVE. NIELSEN A SHOW ABOUT.
FIVE THIRTY ONE NEWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVIE TO FILE
AND FORTY EIGHT SENATOR PORTENT
TINO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR PART INTO YOU KNOW AN
ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE HEALTH
AND CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERAPEUTIC EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THE REPORT YOU KNOW THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SP FOURTEEN MEMBERS
AT A TIME WHEN ONE IN FIVE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IS SERIOUSLY
THINKING ARE THOUGHT ABOUT
SUICIDE. AND ONE IN THREE
STUDENTS HAVE ISSUES THAT THEY
NEED TO DEAL WITH WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO HELP TRAIN THE
PERSONNEL IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNS OF MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND IN PARTICULAR
SUICIDE. SEITEL ISSUES- XP
FOURTEEN DOES THAT IT ALSO
ATTEMPTS TO DE STIGMATIZE
MENTAL HEALTH BY TREATING
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH
EQUALLY FOR OUR STUDENTS AS WE
TRANSITION BACK TO SCHOOL- IN
PERSON THIS IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ITEM. I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TINO MEMBERS THIS IS
IN ROUTE SENATOR RUBIO.
DISCUSSIONAND DEBATE PLEASE
PROCEED. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE I ALSO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
WALKING OUT OF FROM HE'S-
BRINGING THESE ISSUES FORWARD
OUT AS A SCHOOL TEACHER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AND- SEEN. HOW
OUR CHILDREN NOT ONLY ARE
STRUGGLING NOW BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WERE ALREADY DEALING
WITH- IN MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR WE HAD. REALLY HIGH
RATE OF SUICIDE AND JUST SO
MANY INCIDENTS WHERE CHILDREN.
ALMOST COMMITTED SUICIDE SO I
REALLY WANT TO THANK HIM AND I
AGREE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA BY ATKINS I
BASE HI BACKER. HI PORGES I
BRADFORD. COME BY ADAM ARE YOU
COURTESY HI DOLLY FIVE DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ. I GROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. I HER TADO I JONES. I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI
THE MON I REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S
I MEN HI NEWMAN BY NIELSEN. BUT
SHOW BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER.
HI STERN I AM BERG. I Y. CASKEY
I WINNER I WILL I COULD CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. BRADFORD HI.
EGGMAN GROWTH. I NIELSEN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT MILLER ZERO ON THE
URGENCY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY NINE
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANNA. START
OUT BY SAYING WITH RESPECT TO
THIS MEASURE. VEYS MIR AND-
VERY. I WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL.
THANK YOU TO MY EXTRAORDINARY
HARD WORKING CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
A CONTAINER WHO WORKED THIS
CASE GOES OUT ON THIS MEASURE
OVER THE LAST MANY MONTHS.
DEALING WITH THE CHALLENGES
THAT- IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP
NINETEEN PASSED BY THE VOTERS.
THE WE WORK WITH THE ASSESSORS
TO SOLVE THAT ISSUE WE GIVE AN
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY TO THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION TO WITHIN
THE PARAMETERS OF WHAT THE
VOTERS SAID. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY WE KEPT
OUR WORD. WITH RESPECT TO THE
MEETING IMPLEMENTATION AND
INTENT OF THIS MEASURE WITH
RESPECT TO. THE PROP NINETEEN
RESPECT TO THE VOTERS AND THE
VOTE LAST YEAR ON THIS FLOOR
WELL THANK THE FIREFIGHTERS AND
REALTORS FOR EXTRAORDINARY WORK
ON THIS. I THINK IT COULD BE
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND WITH
THAT. ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I RECENTLY
MET WITH THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
HEALDSBURG AND THE SENATOR FROM
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY TO DISCUSS.
PROPOSITION NINETEEN AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY MIGHT BE O. S. V.
SIX SIX EIGHT WHICH WOULD HAVE
DELAYED THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
OF PROP NINETEEN FOM FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. A
MERE TWO AND A HALF MONTHS
AFTER IT WAS ODD- BY THE VOTERS
TO FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD HAVE GIVEN
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
LAWYERS COUNTY ASSESSORS AND
TAXPAYERS MORE TIME TO FIGURE
OUT. HOW BEST TO IMPLEMENT THE
LARGEST CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM SINCE PROP
THIRTEEN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT UNFORTUNATELY WERE NOT
ABLE TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT
AND HAVE MY DEAL INCORPORATED
INTO THE BILL WE HAVE BEFORE US
TODAY. I THANK THE SENATORS SAW
SPECIALLY- TAKEN OUT TIME
BRINGING US. TO THE TABLE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
HOWEVER I WILL BE VOTING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY
BECAUSE OUR COUNTY ASSESSORS
ARE DESPERATE FOR ANY
CLARIFICATION. ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT PROPOSITION NINETEEN
I STOOD ON THIS FLOOR LAST JUNE
AND RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT ACA
ELEVEN WHICH BECAME PROP
NINETEEN ON THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY VALID. THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION SENT A
LETTER WITH TWO PAGES OF
CONCERNS AND COUNTY ASSESSORS.
ARE WARNED OF THE PROBLEMS
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE REST AC
ELEVEN FAMILIES HAVE BEEN HURT
AND THE PROSPECT FOR BUILDING
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH
THROUGH PROPERTY OWNERSHIP. FOR
MANY HAS BEEN DIMINISHED. THE
COLD AT NINETEEN. HAS LEFT
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS UNABLE
TO MAKE TRANSFERS UNDER THE OLD%
RULES DUE TO GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS BEING CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC. THE NUMBER OF
CONSTITUENTS NOT ONLY FROM MY
DISTRICT BUT FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA HAVE REACHED OUT TO
MY OFFICE. HEARING THEIR HORROR
STORIES REVOLVING AROUND PROP
NINETEEN IN TE RUSH TO GET
PROPOSITION NINETEEN WE DIDN'T
PROVIDE ENOUGH TIME. FOR TAX
ASSESSORS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
OUR FAMILIES TO PLAN HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES TO
PROTECT BEARS AND THEIR FUTURE
GENERATIONS PROPERTY. RULE THAT
FAMILIES COUNTED ON FOR NEARLY
FIVE DECADES WENT OUT THE
WINDOW. WE COULD HAVE AND
SHOULD HAVE DONE BETTER S. B.
FIVE THIRTY NINE DOES MAKE AN
ATTEMPT AT RECTIFYING THE
WRONGS AND WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
IT BUT WE ARE STILL FEELING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES BY NOT
DOING MORE. WHICH WE REALLY
NEED TO DO. SENATOR ALI. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE AND I WANT TO FIRST OFF-
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR MANY
HOURS- ON ZOOM- WORKING WITH
THE ASSESSOR'S A CALIFORNIA THE
ASSOCIATION WHO WE THIS THIS
BILL BASICALLY GIVES CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO THE ASSESSORS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS IN PRAGUE
NINETY AND HOW IT SHOULD BE-
HOW THE THIS SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED ALONG WITH THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. SO I
WOULD SHARE THAT- THERE'S
LANGUAGE AND- FIVE NINETEEN
THAT ALLOWS A FAMILY FARMS TO
CONTINUE TO BE FAMILY FARMS
THIS BILL- CLARIFIES HOW THOSE
FAMILY FARMS WILL BE ASSESSED
TO THE ASSESSORS AND HOW THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER ASPECTS- PROP NINETEEN
THAT WERE PASSED DO SOME
SURRENDER THIS BILL HERE- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- AND THE
ASSOCIATIONS THAT WE WORKED
WITH. TIRES THE FIREFIGHTERS
THE REALTORS AND THE LIKES OF-
THIS BILL IS ABOUT- KEEPING
YOUR WORD AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE LEGISLATION OR THE
VALIDATION THAT WAS PASSED IS
IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE STANDARDS FOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU COUPLE
POINTS FIRST ON WITH RESPECT
DELAY OF IMPLEMENTATION DATE WE
LOOKED AT THAT BUT IT'S OUR
VIEW THAT THE VOTERS SPOKE AND
THIS IS WHAT THEY PUT IN AND WE
WERE STILL WE WERE BASICALLY
GUIDED BY THE VOTERS YOU COULD
ARGUE THAT. ANY WAY YOU CHOOSE
THE CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE WE
FELT WE HAD FLEXIBILITY. AS WAS
APPROPRIATELY EXPRESSED. BOTH
ELEMENTS OF THIS MEASURE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST SESSION WE CENTER
HILL INSERT SYNAGOGUES. AND
ALSO THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO TRY
TO REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THIS
VERY SAME THING A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. THE ARGUMENT WITH
RESPECT TO THE LAST MINUTE
ISSUE THAT I'VE TALKED TO A
NUMBER OF FOLKS IN MY JUDGMENT.
IT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS A
VALID A POINT OF VIEW. AND THE
ISSUE WITH THE FAMILY FARMS WAS
A CLARIFICATION APPROPRIATELY
ALTHOUGH THE FARM BUREAU DIDN'T
SUPPORT PROP NIGHT. AC ELEVEN.
WHAT WAS ON THE FLOOR BUT THEN
CHANGED IT WHEN IT WAS PROP
NINETEEN BUT THE CLARIFICATION
WAS APPROPRIATE. AND I GIVE
GREAT CREDIT TO THE INTEGRITY
OF THE FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHERS
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THAT. AND
THE LAST THING I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I. NEEDED THIS BILL
LIKE A LOCKING CLIP. ASTRO VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINSI BASE HI BACKER HI
FORTRESS HI BRADFORD I HAVE A-
HI CORTESE HI DOLLY. I THOUGHT
I TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG
I WENT SO HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE AMOUNT. FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN HI
FOURTEEN TINA I. ROSS HI RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN HI AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS. GROVE. I MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN OTOBO. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON
THE FILE AND FIFTIES SENATOR
LET ALONE BUT I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR LAMONT AN ACT
RELATING TO DEMENTIA. CENTRE
MON. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES SB FORTY EIGHT
WILL IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO RECEIVE A
DIGNIFIED DARED NOT DIAGNOSIS.
DIAGNOSIS AND QUALITY CARE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA
SPECIFICALLY SP FORTY EIGHT
WOULD AUTHORIZE PHYSICIANS AND
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS TO SATISFY
EXISTING CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH A COURSE
THAT ADDRESSES THE SPECIAL CARE
NEEDS OF PATIENTS WITH DEMENTIA
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS A
GROWING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPT IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO ALZHEIMER'S
INCREASED TWO HUNDRED AND 43%
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ALZHEIMER'S WAS
THE THIRD. LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH. WE TO BE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION LESS THAN HALF OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S HAVE BEEN DIED HAVE
BEEN GIVEN A DIAGNOSIS. THE
LAST. THE LACK OF DIAGNOSIS
LEADS TO A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
RELATED. TO COMPLAINING CARE
COST OF CARE AND ENGAGEMENT IN
CLINICAL TRIALS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE PARTIALLY
REMOVED OPPOSITION AND LOOK I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION I DO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
WHO HAS PROVIDED DIRECTION AND
IS WORKING WITH ME AS THIS
BILL. MOVES FORWARD WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THANK YOU SENATOR THE MON
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO THAT IF
YOU WANNA HAVE A CONVERSATION
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE IT OFF THE
FLOOR THANK YOU. SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND THE- AUTHOR
MENTIONED. THAT THESE CASES ARE
ON THE RISE AND AS WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING TO STUDY.
THIS ISSUE WORK ON A TOUR. I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THIS BILL. IS TO HELP US FIND
THAT CURE BECAUSE IF PEOPLE GET
EARLY DIAGNOSIS THAT CAN START
PARTICIPATING IN THE CLINICAL
STUDIES. THERE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO GET THEM A
CAROUSEL. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL NASTRAN I VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO CETER
PAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE AND SUPPORT
NOW IF SP FORTY EIGHT- I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT- I WAS AN
OPPOSITION WHEN IT WAS HEARD IN
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT WAS A
MANDATE ON CONTINUING MEDICAL
EDUCATION BUT I WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA
BARBARA- WHERE WE HAD SOME VERY
I HOPE THINGS ARE VERY POSITIVE
AND GOOD CONVERSATIONS TO. TALK
ABOUT HOWWE TRULY ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL WHICH IS TO
GET EARLY SCREENING. WHAT CAN
WE DO TO TRULY GET INCREASED
EARLY SCREENING FOR DEMENTIA
AND ALZHEIMER'S. RIGHT AND I IT
IS AT MIDNIGHT STRESSED MY
DISAGREEMENT THAT MANDATORY
SINI WASACTUALLY ACHIEVE THAT
BUT WE- CAN DO MORE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- YEAH MY GOOD
FROM SANTA BARBARA AND I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO. BUT THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT AGING- WE TALKED
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN. I
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS ALSO
THE ULTIMATE ALTIZER SOCIAIS
ASIAN I KNOW THAT- SOME OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS WILL
HOPEFULLY BEAR FRUIT IN TERMS
OF ADDITIONAL. AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL- WHEN YOU GET TO THE
SIMPLY ENFORCING IT WAS ENOUGH
TIME TO WORK THIS OUT FORD
VERSION THE BILL WHICH HEARING
RIGHT NOW ON THE FLOOR BUT I
HOPE. EVERYONE WILL. HELP US
KEEP MOVING THIS FORWARD. I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. AND TRYING TO
ACHIEVE THE AIM THAT SHE- SO
MUCH ONCE AND I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT AS WELL- SO I THINK
THIS IS WE'RE ON A REALLY GOOD
PATH. TO TRY TO AGAIN. MAKE
SURE WE GET PEOPLE EARLY
DIAGNOSIS I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN DIEGO POINTED
OUT THIS IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
SO WE CAN ALSO GIVE PEOPLE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT. AS WELL I-
TONIGHT BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN. MEMBERS
SITTING IN HER MANSON THE MON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I. THINK
MA'AM BUT I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. I AT KINS. I BASE. I
BACKER. I PORCHES BY BRADFORD
HI CAN BUY ADAM HI CORTESE I
VALLEY I DON ONE FIVE TORONTO.
HI EGGMAN HI PLEASE FIVE
CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
HERTZBERG'S HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I BEEN. I
NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW OF
VOGUE I PANNED BY FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
HI STERN. FIVE AMBERG I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ROSE HI JONES NIELSEN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT MILLER ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
OH SIX BY SENATOR ROTH AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS CENTER
ALL THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT
CALLING SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO
SIX IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY WITHOUT THIS BILL IN
A SUNSET EXTENSION THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WILL
EXPIRE. SO THE BILL EXTENDS
BOARD OPERATIONS FOR TWO YEARS.
THE MEDICAL BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS STARTING WITH HOW
COMPLAINTS FROM THE PUBLIC OR
HANDLED STRETCHING ALL THE WAY
TO THE END IS THE BOARD MAKES
DECISIONS ABOUT LICENSE
DISCIPLINE. HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
AND QUESTIONS FROM YOU. AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ALIKE. IN
THAT REGARD SIGNIFICANTLY THE
BILL PROPOSES AN ENFORCEMENT
MONITOR AT THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE INDEPENDENT
INFORMATION. ABOUT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING AT THE
MEDICAL BOARD INFORMATION THAT
I HOPE. WILL PROVIDE GUIDANCE
AS TO THE NEXT NECESSARY STEPS
TO SUPPORT THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
IMPORTANT WORK. THE MEASURE
ALSO REINSTATES THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S AUTHORITY TO RECOVER
COSTS INCURRED. DURING
DISAPPOINT ENFORCEMENT CASES.
THIS CHANGE HAS BEEN REQUESTED
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF FOR
MULTIPLE SUNSET REVIEWS AND IT
IS LIKELY TO PROVIDE AT LEAST
SOME ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
OFFSET COSTLY. BUT NECESSARY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WITH
RESPECT TO THE FEE INCREASE
PROPOSED BY THE BOARD AND
ADMINISTRATION. FEEDING FREEZE
IN SOME AMOUNT IS CLEARLY
NECESSARY NOW THIS IS BEEN A
VERY CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT OF
DISCUSSION AS I KNOW EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU ARE AWARE FROM
THE PHONE CALLS EMAILS AND TEXT
THAT YOU'VE BEEN RECEIVING
DURING THE SUNSET. REVIEW
PERIOD FRANKLY THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS BORDERING ON THE
INSOLVENT AND HAS NOT HAD AN
ADJUSTMENT TO FEE INCREASES AN
ADJUSTMENT OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT PORT
OPERATIONS FOR ALMOST FIFTEEN
YEARS. THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE A RESERVE
ACCOUNT EQUAL TO TWO TO FOUR
MONTHS OF EXPENSES IN CONTRAST
TO THIS REQUIREMENT THE MEDICAL
BOARDRESERVE ACCOUNT WILL SOON
BE DOWN TWO POINT SEVEN MONTHS
POINT SEVEN MONTHS. THE
ADMINISTRATION THE UPON THE
BOARD ORIGINALLY PROPOSED A FEE
INCREASE EQUAL TO THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS EVERY
TWO YEARS THE PHYSICIAN GROUPS
SUBJECT TO THE FEE INCREASE
QUESTIONED THE FINANCIAL AND
EXPENSE ASSUMPTIONS ON WHICH
THE FEE PROPOSAL WAS BASED AND
REQUESTED INSTEAD BUT THE
INCREASE OF EIGHTY DOLLARS
EVERY TWO YEARS. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. IN REVIEWING THE
FEE INCREASE ISSUE IT APPEARED.
AND APPEARS THAT A MORE
DETAILED ANALYSIS IS REQUIRED
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT A FEE
INCREASE AT EITHER LEVEL BUT
CLEARLY IF THE INCREASE IS
REQUIRED. SO THE BILL AS
AMENDED INCREASES FEES FOR
PHYSICIANS EIGHTY DOLLARS EVERY
TWO YEARS AND PROVIDES IT AT
THE END OF THE FIRST YEAR OF
THE SUNSET PERIOD. THE
LEGISLATURE SHALL REVISIT THE
V. ISSUE REVIEW BOARD FINANCIAL
DATA AND FURTHER INCREASE FEES
AS APPROPRIATE AND AS
NECESSARY. TO RESTORE THE
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY OF THE BOARD
AND ITS RESERVE ACCOUNTS TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL. THE BILL
ALSO UPDATES REQUIREMENTS FOR
POSTGRADUATE TRAINING PROBATION
SURE BY ACCOMMODATING RESIDENTS
WHO MAY TAKE LEAVE DURING THEIR
POST GRADUATE PROGRAM
ENROLLMENT. PROVIDING THE BOARD
DISCRETION TO APPROVE
APPLICATIONS AND AUTHORIZING
RESIDENCY PROGRAM DIRECTORS TO
VERIFY THAT APPLICANTS SUBMIT
NECESSARY TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. AFTER TAKING SUCH
LEAVE LIKE ALL SUNSET BILLS
THIS MEASURE WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE SHAPE OVER THE NEXT NUMBER
OF MONTHS. AS I DISCUSSED WITH
SOME OF YOU THERE ARE FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THATWE WILL NEED TO
PURSUE IN THE ASSEMBLY
INCLUDING. LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE
ACCREDITATION OF TEACHING
HOSPITALS WERE PHYSICIANS
PRACTICE UNDER SPECIALTY
SPECIAL FACULTY PERMITS. OUR
GOAL IS TO SEND THE BILL TO THE
GOVERNOR THE PROVIDES THE
MEDICAL BOARD WITH THE TOOLS
AND DIRECTION TO ENSURE SWIFT
OUTCOMES FOR CASES. MOST
ESPECIALLY CASES INVOLVING
ALLEGATIONS OF SIGNIFICANT
DEVIATION FROM THE STANDARD OF
CARE THAT RESULTED IN PATIENT
HARM. THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AS YOU KNOW IS JUST THAT IT'S A
PROCESS AND IF THIS BILL PASSES
OUT OF THIS HOUSE. THE BILL
MOVES TO THE ASSEMBLY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD WITH
PATIENTS AND PHYSICIANS. AND
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
CHANGES WERE NECESSARY AND TO
MAKE THIS THE BEST SUNSET
REVIEW BILL POSSIBLE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH SENATOR
PAN. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS- I DO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF- SBA TO SEX AND
APPRECIATE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
RIVERSIDE FOR HIS WORK ON ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL- FULL
DISCLOSURE I AM A LICENSEE OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA- A PRECIADO. THE
CHALLENGES THAT- THAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE- BNP COMMITTEE-
FACE IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
FISCAL. STATUS OF- THE MEDICAL
BOARD. OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND I SHARE- THE
AUTHORS GOAL THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE FISCAL SOLVENCY FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD. BUT I ALSO POINT
OUT AS SOMEONE WHO'S SAT ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE A MUCH CLOSER
EXAMINATION OF THE COSTS. THAT
ARE BEING DRIVEN- THAT THAT
LEADING TO THE FISCAL
INSOLVENCY ISSUES- AND FOR
EXAMPLE- ELSE ESSENTIALLY A-
OVERLY EXPENSIVE COMPUTER
SYSTEM THAT WAS USED NOT JUST
THE MEDICAL BOARD ACROSS THE
CA. ELEVATED AND INTO ME
EXCESSIVE LEGAL FEES BEING
CHARGED TWO BOARDS- FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTION ACTIVITIES-
AND OTHERS AS WELL- BECAUSE
AFTER ALL- LATENCIES WEATHERED
THE MEDICAL BOARD OR OTHER.
HEALTH PROFESSIONS THAT ARE
LICENSED AS A CITY CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW THESE THESE FEES- THEY
YOU KNOW- AND NOT IT'S NOT LIKE
IT'S A FREE TICKET DATES HERE-
AND SOMETIMES THERE'S THAT
THERE'S BEEN A FEELING THAT-
WELL. WE CAN JUST JACK UP FEES-
TO DEAN'S EXPENSES AND THEN SAY
URN AROUND SAY WE NOW NEED TO
INCREASE THE FEES TO COVER
THOSE EXPENSES SO I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A CLOSE ACCOUNTING.
OF WHAT THE REAL EXPENSES ARE
RELATED TO THE ADD TO THE WORK
OF THE BOARD ITSELF AND ITS
ENFORCEMENT AND SO FORTH. A
GREAT AGAIN AGREED WITH THE
GOAL OF- OF A SOLVENCY BUT- WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY BE TRYING TO
LOOK AT HOW WE MINIMISE COSTS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT AND IN THE
BOARDS SO THAT WE'RE NOT
CHARGING EXCESSIVE FEES AFTER
ALL JUST LAST YEAR WE WE'VE
DRASTICALLY RAISE FEES ON MANY
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS
LICENSEES- AS AS WELL- SO AGAIN
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE GOOD
WORK OF- MY- GOOD FRIEND FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I KNOW HE IS-
WORKING HARD TO ADDRESS THESE
PARTICULAR ISSUES AND- ALSO
APPRECIATE HIS COMMITMENT ALSO
DRESS A POLICY ISSUE THAT WAS
UP FROM LAST YEAR- IT'S
ADDRESSING THE APPOINTMENT. OF-
OF- FACULTY- ACADEMIC HEALTH
CENTERS THAT- WHO CAN THEN
PRACTICE WITHOUT A LICENSE THAT
THOSE IMPORTANTISSUE TO TRY TO
RESOLVE- BUT I DO ASK THAT WE
HAVE AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL SO
WE CAN CONTINUE THE WORK-
MOVING FORWARD- AND RENEW THE
MEDICAL BOARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR. MEMBER ANY FURTHER.
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NINE CENTER OFFERS LIKE TO
CLOSE FOR A MINUTE PRESENT JUST
WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE- THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND I CONCURRED
CLEARLY OUR GOAL IS TO ENSURE
FINANCIAL FINANCIAL SOLVENCY OF
THE BOARD WHILE ENSURING. COST
EFFICIENCY OF THE BOARD
OPERATIONS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE FEES THAT WE
AUTHORIZED FOR PHYSICIANSAND
OTHERS SUBJECT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD ARE ONLY THOSE NECESSARY.
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO THE TO ENSURE
THE OP CONTINUED OPERATION OF
THAT BOARD AND I COMMITTED TO
ALL OF YOU THAT THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. WITH THIS
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE ABOVE.
I THINK YOU SAID IRAQ MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BATES I BACKER I FORTUS.
BRADFORD HI COULD BUY A FIVE
COURTESY I. DALLY. NO DODD I
DURAZO HI ADNAN I GLAZER FIVE
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. BUT SHOW A VOGUE NO PAN
FIVE FORTINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG HI
BY CAL SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL
KNOW PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. PORCHES GROVE. HER
TADO. NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY TWO
MILLS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO OUR
LAST ITEM OF THE DAY FIVE FILE
I'M FIFTY TWO SENATOR CARDERO
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR KABBADI AT- AN ACT
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CENTER GLOBAL AERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT WILL HELP PROMOTE THE
IMPORTANT THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA BY
STABBING A PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY THE I. BANK. TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO QUALIFYING SIGNIFIES
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INCREASED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
PROMOTE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ING IN
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL YES SENATOR
LEMOND OBJECTION TO ROLL CALL
YOU WANT TO SPEAK. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU I RISE IN THE
JOINT A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF SB
SIX TO FIVE AND I THINK THE
SENATOR FROM SALINAS FOR
BRINGING THIS MATTER FORWARD
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION OR CDFI SPLAYED
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL SYSTEM AND THEY
DESERVE OUR SUPPORT DURING MY
TIME AS BANKING TURN THE
ASSEMBLY NOW IN THE SENATE I
OFTEN HEAR FROM CONSTITUENTS
AND FELLOW MEMBERS THAT BIG
BANKS ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I WELL I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT FEELING I DO
NOT WANT US TO OVERLOOK THE
WORK. THE GREAT WORK THAT CDF
EYES ARE DOING EVERY DAY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CDFI IS ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE AREAS THAT
MANY OF US CARE ABOUT SUCH AS
FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT SMALL BUSINESS LENDING
AND PROGRAMS THAT HELP THE
UNBANKED AND UNDERBANKED MANY
SEE IF EYES ARE READY TO EXPAND
BUT THEY MUST BE ADEQUATELY
CAPITALIZED IN ORDER TO GROW
THEIR BALANCE SHEET AND MAKE
MORE LOANS THIS BILL IS STABBED
TO GRANT PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK THAT WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL FUNDING THAT
ALLOWS CDFI IS TO GROW THEIR
LOAN PORTFOLIOS. ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT THIS MODEL
IS THAT EVERY DOLLAR OF OUR
PUBLIC INVESTMENT CAN BE USED
TO ATTRACT ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
THE PRIVATE CAPITAL ALONGSIDE
THIS BILL THE SENATOR FROM
SALINAS AND I LED A BUDGET
REQUEST BUT IS ALSO INCLUDED IN
THE STATE AND ASSEMBLY'S BUDGET
AGREEMENT ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK
WHICH PROVIDE SEVENTY MILLION
INVESTMENT IN THE FUND
ESTABLISHED BY THIS BILL IN
ADDITION TO LEVERAGING PRIVATE
CAPITAL WE MUST ALSO LEVERAGE
EXPERTISE FROM. THAT CD IF I.
BRING IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
HAVE SERVED. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE. WHERE WE DO NECESSARY
NEED TO RE AND THE WHEEL BUT
INSTEAD WE CAN LOOK. TO MODEL
THAT ARE ALREADY WORKING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES GROW. AS WE LOOK TO
REBUILD FROM THE PANDEMIC I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
DEVICE CAN HELP US MAKE
CALIFORNIA A MORE EQUITABLE
PLACE TO CALL HOME. I HOPE THIS
BILL IS. ONE OF THE FIRST
CRITICAL STEP IN ESTABLISHING
ONGOING PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SEE IF
I WAS WORKING IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU FOR
THE LIMO ON FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. SEND A COVER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IN A VOTE THANK YOU MA'AM
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM FIVE
THREE NINE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO WE'RE GOING TO LIVE CALL
ON FIVE ITEMS THEN WE'RE GOING
TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TO MOVE BILLS TO
INACTIVE FOR THE INACTIVE FILE.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK FOR LUNCH AND WE WILL
RETURN BACK FROM LUNCH AT
TWELVE FORTY FIVE SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH LOOKING A CALL
ON THE FIVE MEASURES WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BY ADAM I HER
TADO. I. WE MOAN I MELINDA'S I
NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE SP SEVEN FIFTY TWO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS I BASE. DALLY. EGGMAN I.
GROVE JONES. THE MON I.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. GROVE I.
NIELSEN A CELLO BOW I. STERN I
WELL I. THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. EXCUSE ME I
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES OUR MEMBERS REMOVED THE
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN SP TWO
TWO- PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS I BASE. FOR
JUST. GROVE. MON HI NIELSEN.
FIVE THIRTY ONE MILLS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING THE FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR SP FOUR FOUR
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS I FOR JUST. I
HAVE I EVER I. MON I. WE'LL
SEND. FIVE THIRTY NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT SP EIGHT OH THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
I GORGEOUS I. MON. NIELSEN
RUBIO. STERN HI I WILKE. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO MOVE ANY BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST- OF
THIS FANTASTIC OFFER CENTER
LABOR PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING
ITEM TO AN ACTIVE FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE IS B. TWO TWO EIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR REQUIRED THE
DESK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS ANYONE
ELSE. CENTRE HER TADO. MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
SP. SIX FORTY EIGHT. TO BE AN
ACTIVE FILE AND AS WELL AS A
FINAL ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE
SB SIXTY ONE TO BE AN ACTIVE
MONTHLY DEATH ONE NOTE THANK
YOU MEMBERS ANYWAY. FILE I'M.
TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU IN PERSON I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO INCLUDE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR SP FOUR
NINETY TWO TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE
REGULAR HER TADO MEMBERS ANYONE
ELSE. SEEING AND HEARING NO ONE
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK FOR LUNCH PLEASE BE BACK
ON THE FLOOR AT TWELVE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
ARE IN RECESS.
MEMBERS ARE
RECESS HAS ENDED I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE VERY MUCH FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT CALLS ON BILLS.
SENATOR STERN FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE. I AM REQUESTING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO MAKE A
BRIEF STATEMENT PRIOR TO THE
LIFTING OF THE CALLS ON. THIS
BEFORE NINETEEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU CENTER
STARNES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
LIVE CALLS ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
SENATOR. I'M SORRY BUT YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE THE SAME FOR YOU
PLEASE MAKE A STATEMENT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
BRIEF RECESS HERE- I AM
COMMITTED TO. MAKING AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL BE ARTICULATED IN A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. I WILL
SUBMIT A DRAFT COPY TO ALL
BEFORE LEAVING HERE TODAY- AND
THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED TO THE
FILE THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE
MOMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN. RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
GOING TO LIFT THE COALS ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY S. P. TWO THIRTEEN
SENATOR CORTESE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I ADKINS I
BRADFORD. DODD GROVE. HER TADO.
THANK YOU KAREN WALKER. THE MON
I. MAN NIELSEN. PAN POURTANT
TINO. ROTH RUBIO. STERN AMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
BRADFORD DODD. GROWTH HER TADO.
CAN LONGER I. MEN WE'LL SEND.
PAM FOUR TWENTY NOW. ROTH RUBIO
STERN AMBERG- BRADFORD HI.
SENATOR HUESO. WAY SO I KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD GROVE HER TADO. MEN YEAH
NIELSEN'S. PAM THE REPORT IN
TINA. RALPH RUBIO. STERN AMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE HELP THE
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DODD NO.
GROVE HER TADO. MIN NIELSEN PAM
FORTUNE TINO. RALPH RUBIO STERN.
AMBERG. CENTER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
TWELVE SP A FOUR EIGHTY SENATOR
STERN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HAVE I
EVER. GLAZER LET MY OWN I.
NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
S. FOUR NINETEEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. ALLEN I.
BACKER BRADFORD. KABY YELLOW.
DALLY I. GOD EGGMAN. GLAZER.
CONSOLIDATES I. HER TADO. LET
MY OWN SYSTEM I. NIELSEN PAN.
ROTH WILLING TO RUBIO. WEINER I.
PRIME BACKER HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BRADFORD COME BY AND- DODD.
EGGMAN GLAZER- TODD. NEIL CAN.
ROTH RUBIO. REAL CLOSE AND
PLEASE CALL THEM TO MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. BRADFORD BY ADAM.
GOD EGGMAN. GLAZER HER TADO.
NIELSEN CAN. ROTH RUBIO BUYS
TWENTY THREE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALL MEMBERS ON
FILE ITEM TWELVE WE FAILED TO
RECORD A VOTE OF THE MEMBERS SO
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THAT BACK
UP AND ALLOW THAT MEMBER TO
VOTE THIS IS SP. FOUR EIGHTY.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THIRTY EIGHT
ALL EYES NOSE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO FILE I'M TWENTY S.
P. TWO THIRTEEN. BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROSS YEAH. YES HER TADO. MAN
NIELSEN. PAM POURTANT TINO.
RALPH RUBIO. STERN AMBERG. BUYS
TWENTY KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
FAILS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS ALTHOUGH I DO THINK WE
ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
BRADFORD. WE'RE GOING TO RE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL.
RECONSIDERATION ON SP TWO
THIRTEEN HAS BEEN GRANTED
THIRTY FOUR EYES NOSE ZERO.
MEMBERS WERE JUST RECONCILING
THE VOTES SO STAY TUNED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR STERN I
WILL START WITH YOU THEN
SENATOR CORTESE WILL COME TO
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
ACTUALLY ASKED TO MOVE- FILING
THIRTY TWO SP TWO NINE ONE AND
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AS P. FIVE
EIGHTY TWO TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THE DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR
CORTESE MOVED FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON S. B. TWO
THIRTY. AND WE DID THAT ALREADY
SO YOU ARE GOOD TO GO SIR THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA MOVE IF YOU
MOVE THE BILL TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
ANYTHING ELSE ON OUR MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK THIS ENTIRE WEEK NOT
ONLY ON. A HOUSE OF ORIGIN
DEADLINE- BUT ALSO ON OBVIOUSLY
ALL OF THE BUDGET WORK DONE
INTO THE EVENING YESTERDAY LET
ME ADD OUR THANKS- AS A SENATE
BODY TO THE DESK STAFF FLOOR
STAFF THE SERGEANTS BERNIE THE
SECRETARY- FOR THE WORK. THANK
YOU CONTINUALLY DO IN THE MIDST
OF CHALLENGES WE APPRECIATE YOU
SO MUCH. AND WITH THAT OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY JUNE SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU US
SENATOR ACTIONS THE SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED MEMBERS WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND.